Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Es gab Klagen, dass der Bonus trägt, der letzten Sendung einen nachhaltigen Ohrwurm erzeugt hat. Das ist natürlich ein Problem. Weißt du, was dagegen helfen könnte?
Natürlich, ein belegtes Brot mit Schinken.
Politik Nummer dreihundertsechsundsiebzig vom dreizehnten Januar zwanzigeinundzwanzig,
Ich habe übrigens noch kein einziges Mal die Jahreszahl falsch gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, wann mir das das letzte Mal passiert ist, aber normalerweise stolpert man das neue Jahr und denkt sich so, ach, was ist schon neues Jahr? Und ich glaube, diesmal sind wir alle so
draufgedrillt. Ja, nee, ist wirklich ein neues Jahr. Zwanzig zwanzig ist weg. Go, go, go, das es keiner mehr falsch macht.
Also ich sage es äh nicht oft falsch, aber ich ähm tippe das oft falsch. Ich sehe, dass ich da Dateinamen mit falschen Daten, Bezeichnungen anlege und so. Ähm da bin ich nicht.
Du forderst es ja gerade zu heraus. Du, so kein kein Wunder, dass ich die Pandemie und die Krise fortwährend äh noch mehr in die Zukunft verlagert.
Wenn man die ganze Zeit äh die Vergangenheit beschwört. Wir müssen jetzt äh weiß ja, goldene zwanziger und so.
Ich kann es nicht mehr hören.
Trotzdem, wir bleiben optimistisch, denn.
Wir sind die Optimisten in Person, zumindest für die eine, für die einen anderthalb Stunden, die wir im in der Woche hier Podcasten.
Ja, das auch aus gutem, guten Grund, denn äh mit Pessimismus kommt man überhaupt nicht voran, wenn man nicht.
Mit Fessimismus kommst du genauso weit voran, es macht nur weniger Spaß.
Naja, ich lasse es mal gelten.
Ja, aber sonst noch irgendwas.
Sonst noch was, ja, Feedback haben wir.
Feedback haben wir, genau. Feedback. Ähm.
Wir haben in der letzten Sendung äh habe ich am Rande über Singapur gesprochen und habe da gesagt, dass in Singapur
viele Regeln und hohe Strafen geil sind, mein Satz war, glaube ich, das finden die da irgendwie geil. Dazu kommentiert Kangwände.
Hallo ihr beiden, ich muss doch mal ein Kommentar zu Singapur abgeben, zum Hintergrund. Ich habe dort einige Zeit gewohnt,
an der National University auf Singapur studiert, unter anderem Geschichte. Der in Singapur, also der des also.
Bestrafungsrecht, ne? Also Pönal, der Pönalco,
ähm das ist ein schönes, das ist übrigens der deutsche Fachbegriff für äh äh Shitstorm.
Ja
So äh also der der Peanel Code in äh Singapur ist ein koloniales Überbleibsel. Malaysia war eine britische Kolonie. Das hat sich die dortige Gesellschaft nicht ausgesucht.
Sondern der indische Peanel-Code wurde von den Briten auf das,
Gebiet des heutigen Singapur ausgeweitet. Das erklärt zum Beispiel der betrakonischen Strafen für Homosexualität, die praktisch genau dem damaligen Sexual- und Moralverständnis der Briten entspricht, sowie,
körperliche Züchtigung, das Caning, das Schlagen mit einem Stock als Form der Strafe gibt's in Singapur tatsächlich,
immer noch. Das war auch das, was ich mit drakonischen Strafen ansprechen wollte. Nun hatten die Singapurer genug Zeit.
Seit der Unabhängigkeit sich einen neuen äh Peanel Code zu geben.
Ich finde es aber unfair, gerade, wenn man so ein bisschen über Singapur und wie geil sie drakonische Strafen finden, herzieht auf den kolonialen Kontext äh.
Finde es aber fair, gerade wenn man ein bisschen über Singapur und wie drakonische Strafen finden herzieht, auf den kolonialen Kontext zu verweisen und auch zu sagen, aus welcher Gesellschaft nämlich dem viktorianischen England diese drakonischen Strafen ursprünglich stammten
und im Übrigen wollte ich noch sagen, dass Dorian total geiles Tipp von mir im Eisfach,
nicht im Kühlschrank, dann stinkt alles aufbewahren. Durian ist super fettig und friert deshalb nicht richtig ein. Wenn man sie dann essen will, dann nimmt man eine Portion aus dem Eisfach und lässt sie leicht,
Aufwärmen. Dadurch ist der Geschmackgeruch dann auch grade, wenn man grade erst anfängt, Dorian zu essen,
nicht so überwältigend. Ich habe euch trotzdem lieb und finde den Podcast voll geil. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Ja, vielen Dank dir auch für den Hinweis. Äh tatsächlich wusste ich, dass nicht mit dem, dass das äh seinen Ursprung im Viktorianischen ähm.
England hat. Ähm oder in der Kolonialisierung. Insofern danke auch dafür. Wir haben da in den Kommentaren noch ein bisschen weiter drüber diskutiert, weil ich natürlich mich dann schon auf den Punkt.
Fokussiere das Singapur irgendwann in den sechziger Jahren äh äh unabhängig wurde und äh ich glaube siebenundsechzig war das und ähm,
konnten hatten ja jetzt seitdem Zeit, sich das mit den Stockheben vielleicht auch zu überlegen. Ähm.
Allerdings äh muss man vielleicht auch dazu sagen, also wenn man jetzt nur dieses dieses ganze diese Straferei, ne, wenn wir jetzt mal äh völlig überholte Moralvorstellungen mal außen vor lässt und absolut inakzeptable Gesetze dazu.
Ähm ist das so, dass.
Ich den Eindruck habe und auch lese, dass die da eigentlich relativ happy damit sind. Es ist tatsächlich so, ähm diese diese enorm hohen Strafen kommen dann natürlich auch selten zum,
zum Einsatz, ja, weil sich die Leute natürlich auch an an diese Regeln halten. Und da klebt halt kein,
ähm Kaugummi am Boden oder so was, wo du lang läufst. Da liegt auch keine Hundescheiße rum, ne? Das sieht aus wie äh ja wie wie gerändert diese ganze Stadt, weil weil,
ähm.
Und ich ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass das oder das äh dass sich das längst in einer in der Kultur niedergeschlagen hat.
Und das nicht mehr nur funktioniert wegen dieser hohen Strafen, ja? Und die ganzen Leute rennen und sagen, boah, könnte ich doch endlich mal hier in der U-Bahn Döner essen wieder, ne? Das ist, glaube ich, nicht so. Und ich glaube, würde man diese Strafen abschaffen, würde da jetzt auch nicht
dieses Level an zivilisiertheit zusammenbrechen. Und ich glaube aber, dass sich das.
Dass sie gleichzeitig natürlich diese Sorge haben oder glauben, dass das nur während dieser Strafen so ist,
aufgrund dieser Strafen so ist. Und da denke ich, kommt genau das äh Spannende, was kann, uns hier sagt.
Wenn da mal einmal sowas etabliert wird, wie jetzt zum Beispiel eine ähm,
Homophobie oder diese hohen Strafen. Dass sich das kulturell weiterträgt, selbst dann, wenn es nicht mehr von außen draufgedrückt wird, sondern,
ne? Diese, das, das ist eine Prägung, die überdauert, die ist stabil. Und das ist natürlich auf eine Weise auch schockierend zu sehen. Insofern ist dieser Hinweis, das hat seinen Ursprung.
In den kolonialisierenden Vorstellungen der Briten. Ähm schon sehr, sehr wichtig. Ich frage mich aber auch, ne.
Ob man nicht dann jetzt wirklich fast fünfzig Jahre später sagen muss, so okay, die hatten genug Zeit, sich das anders zu überlegen. Insofern wollen sie's wahrscheinlich tatsächlich, ne, also ähm.
Weiß jetzt nicht, ob ob man ob das für die Singapur, oder sagt man singapurisch oder Singapurianische? Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Bevölkerung von Singapur schmeichelhafter ist, wenn man sagt, eure Strafen haben sich die äh,
kolonialisierenden Briten ausgedacht? Oder wenn man sagt, okay, ihr ihr habt das inzwischen als eure eigene Kultur,
bin ich mir unsicher. Insofern denke ich, ist der Hinweis genau richtig, den Kang hier bringt. Man sollte das zumindest ähm erwähnen, wenn man, vor allem, wenn man darüber ein bisschen lästert. Das haben wir hier mit nachgeholt.
Andere Länder, andere Sitten
Kann ich dir nur zu sagen. Und ich meine, ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir in Deutschland nicht auch äh so Überhänger hätten. Ich meine, hier gibt's ja auch zahlreiche Regelungen, die irgendwann mal die Nazis beschlossen haben und wo wir irgendwie auch nicht so richtig auf die Kette kriegen, das zu ändern, wo es teilweise einfach Jahrzehnte und Generationen braucht, bis äh.
Bis sie den Mist wieder raus hast. Homophobie in Deutschland ja übrigens auch, ne. Also braucht man sich jetzt als grade als Deutscher nicht irgendwie großartig hinzustellen und auf äh die äh singaporeanische auf die Singapurische ähm.
Perspektive auf Homosexualität so großartig herabblicken. Ja, das haben wir uns noch nicht verdient.
Ja oder Homöopathie, so alles alles, was mit hohem anfängt, scheint ein bisschen äh im schwierigen Bereich zu sein.
Das ist zum Beispiel etwas, ja, wo man in Deutschland sich auch fragen müsste, ob man da nicht eventuell auch wieder die Stockhiebe einführt. Ja, also du, das ist alles im Fluss.
Ja, ich.
Leichte Schläge auf den Hinterkopf, erhöhen das Denkvermögen.
Oh es ist Zeit zum nächsten Thema zu kommen.
Okay. Also kulturelle Prägung durch Gesetze überdauert Generationen und das ist ein sehr spannendes Beispiel.
Ja und man und das muss einem ja auch erstmal auffallen, ne, dass mir immer wieder einfällt ist,
als äh in Berlin so nach der äh Wende, da gab's ja hier Regierungswechsel und auf einmal rot-grün, äh Koalition hat nicht lang gehalten und so. Aber eine der ersten Maßnahmen, die sie dann gemacht haben, war, äh ein äh,
eine alte Regelung, die noch aus der ähm äh aus der,
Gott, ist das alles schon wieder so lange her, jetzt fällt mir noch nicht von der richtigen Begriffe ein, die aus der Besatzungszeit nach dem Krieg
Ja, gab's halt noch so eine Regelung, die quasi den Alliierten äh stationierten Soldaten äh es erlaubt hätte, jederzeit einfach in Berlin
zumindest äh einfach jemanden zu erschießen. So, das war halt noch im Gesetz. So wurde jetzt nicht so oft angewendet so, aber,
hätte das jetzt einer gemacht. So, dann äh wär's halt tatsächlich rechtlich abgesichert gewesen. Hat sich halt auch keiner so richtig angeguckt. Das war aber irgendwie im rot-grünen Senat äh
hatte das jemand so auf dem Zettel? Hat gesagt, hier kommt das das ändern wir dann doch mal bitte gleich.
Ist ein bisschen peinlich, ne? Na ja, okay.
Dann haben wir noch einen Kommentar von Max, und zwar hatten wir ja über den Digital Services Act in seiner jetzigen äh Vorschlagsfassung der Kommission gesprochen und da ging es um die Transparenz,
der Werbe.
Ähm der Werbung auf den Social Media Plattformen, nämlich dass sie äh welche Zielgruppen es gibt und welche Werbeanzeigen dort geschaltet.
So und der sagt, Max, zu den Transparenzpflichten von großen Social Media Plattformen. Wenn die veröffentlichen müssen, A, welche Reichweite eine Anzeige hat und B welche Zielgruppe das hat.
Kann man ja wunderbar leicht rekonstruieren, wie viele AfDfreunde mit Erektionsstörungen auf Facebook sind oder wie viele Senioren mit Interesse für Fahrräder. Oder, oder, oder. Und wenn man angezeigt
bekommt, warum man eine Anzeige sieht. Also in welcher Zielgruppe man ist,
wird das auch manchen die Augen öffnen. Also jetzt muss man hier sagen, ich habe da auch, bin da auch erst drüber gestolpert, weil ich dachte, nee, nee, das steht ja nicht. Ähm.
Für die einzelne Person dran.
Dass dass sie einen AfD-Wähler mit steht ja nicht dran hier, dein Nachbar ist ein AfD-Wähler mit Erektionsstörung, aber was er natürlich richtig erkennt ist, sollte es so sein, dass AfD-Wähler spezifisch äh getaget werden in der Werbung.
Dann könnte man das dadrin erkennen. Ja und das wäre sicherlich nicht uninteressant. Ich glaube aber nicht unbedingt, dass man diese ähm.
Dass wir am Ende diesen Detailgrad an ähm.
Haben werden, aber es wäre tatsächlich ein interessanter Punkt, wenn man vielleicht sieht so, du siehst diese Werbung,
weil wir dich für einen, für eine Nazisau halten. Wer, wer ja durchaus äh könnte ja einigen äh einige dazu bewegen.
Darüber nachzudenken. Ich fand das einen ganz interessanten Gedanken. Auf jeden Fall wäre diese Transparenz, das hatten wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, ähm.
Wahrscheinlich relativ wichtig. Auch während ich dennoch glaube, dass das am Ende etwas wäre, wo sich.
Weniger die Allgemeinheit mit Auseinandersetzung,
als dann eben Datenjournalistinnen, die da spezifischen Fragestellungen sehr genau auf den Grund gehen. Also ist jetzt, ne, dass wir nicht irgendwie so, dass da abends die Leute sagen, gucken, komm, wir gucken uns nochmal wieder hier die.
Von Facebook an, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so die bekannten, üblichen und hoffentlich wachsende äh Daten journalistinnen, dann da regelmäßig drauf schauen und sagen, hier da läuft wieder was oder so. Das das denke ich, ist schon,
zu erwarten und eventuell natürlich auch, dass man dass man sagt so okay hier AfD Wähler haben Erektionsprobleme, das wäre ja dann.
Ich mein, gut wäre jetzt keine bahnbrechende Erkenntnis, aber äh auch sowas muss ja erforscht werden.
Ich hoffe mal, die, ja, ich hoffe mal, AfD-Wähler werden demnächst vor allem Elektionsprobleme haben, das wäre mir ehrlich gesagt wichtiger.
Da kommt wieder hier der der Linksfaschist durch bei dir Tim.
Sondern womit wir beim Thema wären, äh auf das sich alle gefreut haben. Ähm.
In den USA gab es am sechsten Januar ähm.
Ein ein Vorkommen eine Reihe an Vorkommnissen, die wir, das müssen wir, glaube ich, vielleicht ganz klar sagen, jetzt nur aus so einer Metaperspektive ohne Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit
besprechen, weil wir eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass ihr das alle in dem Ausmaß verfolgt habt, wie es euch interessiert. Man kann ja seit Tagen eigentlich keine
Seite mehr öffnen, ohne dass dieses Thema besprochen wird. Insofern kommen wir nach einem kurzen Besprechen dessen, was da passiert ist, auf die
netzpolitischen Perspektiven darauf. Ähm und zwar kam es zu einer.
Demonstration in Washington am Rande der äh Zeremonie.
Anerkennung des,
Wahlergebnisses. Und zwar ist es ja so, dass die USA laut Verfassung ja, das ist ja eine Verfassung, die vor Zeiten des Internets äh geschrieben wurde. Äh im Prinzip dieses Wahlsystem haben, wo die Leute nicht direkt wählen.
Für die meisten Verfassungen übrigen. Im Übrigen, also es ist verbreitet. Alles vor dem Internet passiert.
Also die Leute, ja genau, aber in äh spezifisch in den USA, die Leute wählen nicht direkt, sondern der Staat, die Leute wählen für ihren Bundesstaat, Wahlpersonen. Diese Wahlpersonen kommen dann nach Washington und wählen.
Den Präsidenten. Und das hat, denke ich, sein.
Grund irgendwie darin, dass man äh irgendwie eine nachvollziehbare Wahl schaffen wollte, wo dann eben diese überschaubare Anzahl Wahlpersonen in Washington dem Präsidenten wählt, das Ganze als ein Dokument, als ein,
Akt, der stattfindet, Transparenz dokumentierbar ist, ja? Während vielleicht eine Nationsweite Wahl so einfach nicht gelungen wäre. Äh, wie dem auch sei, völlig antiquiertes System, fürchterliche Probleme, weil eben ähm,
Die Anzahl der Wahlpersonen pro Staat,
Nur, ich glaube, alle zehn Jahre, festgelegt wird anhand des Zinses oder noch seltener und gleichzeitig in den Staaten man durch die durch geschicktes Bauen von Wahlbezirken eben.
Sehr,
sein den Einfluss einer Partei und den und eben durch den Zinses den Einfluss eines Staates Ungleichgewichten kann.
Wie dem auch sei, es gibt dann eben eine eher formale Situation, wo der
Vizepräsident als Zeremonienmeister aus den ganzen Staaten, die Stimmen auszählt und das ist im Prinzip die tatsächliche Wahl.
Des Präsidenten
Und es gab ja bisher zwei parallele Realitäten in den USA seit der Wahl. Nämlich die eine wo ganz klar war, Donald Trump hat die Wahl gewonnen und die andere, wo man gesehen hat, dass er die nicht gewonnen hat.
Und dieser Tag, der sechste Januar war eben der, an dem diese beiden Realitäten aufeinander knallen.
War der sechste Januar, oder?
Und jetzt sammeln sich da halt eine Reihe von Leuten angestachelt von primär der immer wiederkehrenden Behauptungen Donald Trumps. Die Wahl wäre gestohlen. Es wäre massiver Wahlbetrug habe stattgefunden. Eine Behauptung, die nirgendwo,
auch nur im Ansatz äh Bestätigung gefunden hat, ja? Jedes Gericht, überall wo die hingegangen sind, wurde gesagt, so
absoluter Unsinn, was ihr hier behauptet. Ihr habt keinerlei Belege, da brauchen wir uns gar nicht anzugucken, teilweise wurde das noch nicht mal äh verhandelt, weil das, was der äh Giuliani da äh vorgelegt hat, so,
absurd war, dass sie dass die Gerichte gesagt haben, nee, tut mir leid, da brauchen wir uns, das ist besteht den Lachttest nicht in der Poststelle so und ähm.
Nicht nur das, sondern äh teilweise sind sie dann vor Gericht auch überhaupt nicht mit dem Argument, es sei habe Wahlbetrug gegeben vor ähgegangen. Also die haben das dann teilweise noch nicht mal mehr behauptet, sie haben nur danach in den Medien behauptet, dass sie das,
behauptet hätten.
Ja
Ja, weil sie selbst wissen, dass sie in dem Moment vielleicht einfach mal schnell aus der Anwaltskanzlei äh rausgeschmissen werden. Ähm ja oder aus den Anwalts ähm wie nennt man das, diese Gruppenberuf,
gruppen, genau, wo sie ja den Giuliani jetzt vielleicht auch rauswerfen wollen. Also es ist halt äh es hat dann natürlich alles.
Weder Hand noch Fuß und das Absurde ist auch, ich meine das ist so viel Absurd da dran, aber eine der Sachen, die da sehr absurd ist, dass auch von den Senatoren zum Beispiel ähm ja auch teilweise behauptet wurde
die mit dem selben Wahlzettel in dieser Wahl selber auch grade wieder gewählt wurden,
Also würde sozusagen ihre These stimmen, müsste ja auch ihre eigene Wahl unter Umständen schiefgelaufen sein, was ja irgendwie nicht ist. Also es ist einfach ein absurdes Spektakel und ein
Beispiel dafür, wie zerrüttet die öffentliche Diskussion in den USA mittlerweile,
wir haben das hier nur ansatzweise und da ist es halt einfach schon ja, pandemisch.
So, was passiert? Ähm durch die ewig wiederholte,
Lüge, es habe ein Wahlbetrug äh gegeben, versammeln sich Anhänger Donald Trumps in Washington und.
Stürmen tatsächlich das Capitol. Und kommen
ich weiß nicht wie viele hunderte oder tausende in dieses Gebäude reingekommen sind, die sind in die Sitzungssäle gestürmt, die haben
Computer aus Büros gestohlen, die haben irgendwie das Büro von unter anderem das Büro von Nancy Pelosi, irgendwie verwüstet und äh Fotos gemacht, wie sie da irgendwie am Schreibtisch sitzen bei noch nicht gesperrten Computern
Ähm Scheiben wurden eingeschlagen, was was gab's noch Schönes?
Ja, sind da auch äh durch die Räume gezogen, die Abgeordneten haben sich äh teilweise in ihre Büros eingeschlossen und die sind da halt äh rumgelaufen, haben irgendwie alles Mögliche auch geklaut und
äh diverse Zerstörungen angerichtet und vor allem sehr viel Angst und Schrecken verbreitet. Und es sind äh diverse Leute zu Schaden gekommen.
Ja
Spannend finde ich in dem Zusammenhang, genau, also es gab mehrere Tote, ja. Aber da fragt man sich also bei den meisten Bildern, die man davon sieht.
Fragt man sich dann schon.
Wie das da noch irgendwie zu Toten gekommen ist, ne? Weil was du süß ist, dass hier mehr oder weniger relativ ungehindert einfach in dieses in dieses Gebäude reinstürmen können. Du siehst irgendwelche Bilder, wo auch Polizisten im Capitol mit den Leuten irgendwelche Selfies machen und so.
Das äh das fand ich schon eher äh besonders äh beeindruckend, oder?
Man sah auch, man sah auch Situationen, wo Polizisten versucht haben, äh Wege zu versperren und dann die Leute reingedrückt haben und dann teilweise die Leute da fast erdrückt wurden. Also.
Polizisten oder was auch immer für ein Personal da grade am Start war. Da ist auf jeden Fall einiges schief gegangen. Dementsprechend sind ja dann auch äh glaube ich zwei hohe Beamte der Kapitels auch zurückgetreten.
Weil das halt einfach eine totale Katastrophe war, sicherheitstechnisch.
Das auf jeden Fall und man muss sich hier, also ich meine, da waren Leute, die hatten irgendwie ähm Hoodies an, auf denen dran stand, sechster Januar zwanzig zwanzig Bürgerkrieg. Ja und.
Konnte ja keiner ahnen, dass es äh na ja.
Das konnte ja keiner ahnen, ähm dass sie das ernst meinen, ja? Und die jetzt muss man natürlich das Ganze vergleichen mit den Black Lives Matter Protest.
Wo mit, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie zigtausende
sofort verhaftet wurden mit Tränengasgranaten und mit Gummi äh ähm Geschossen irgendwie
malträtiert wurden, man kann das zum Beispiel auch erinnern an diese schöne Situation, wo Donald Trump
sich irgendwie vor die Kirchen äh in der Nähe des Weißen Hauses mit einer Bibel stellen wollte und die da vorher die Straße freigekärchert haben, ne? Nichts von dem.
War an diesem Teint, ist an diesem Tag passiert, ja? Und gab einen sehr schönen äh sehr schönes Bild, wo irgendwie so ein.
Einer von diesen Trump-Spinnern quasi in dem in diesem Sitzungssaal vorne steht und irgendwie ein Selfie macht,
ja und wo dazu gesagt wird, so, also wo derjenige, der das getwittert hat, dazu kommentiert, ist bis dahin zu schaffen, ohne erschossen zu werden.
Ist das sinnbild von weißem Privileg.
Und wenn diese gleiche Gruppierung, die dort ähm randaliert hat, wenn die überwiegend, sagen wir mal, braun oder schwarz gewesen wäre, ne, dann hätte das, glaube ich, ganz anders ausgesehen. Und das finde ich wirklich.
Finde ich eigentlich mit das krasseste.
Ja, man muss an der Stelle muss man ja auch schon die Frage stellen, inwiefern ist
sozusagen dieses nicht eingreifen auch systemisch unterstützt worden. Ich meine alleine erstmal die der nicht ein Satz diverser Mittel, also bei ganzen BNM Protesten, da gab's irgendwie Panzer auf der Straße, Hubschrauber in der Luft, ne,
davon war irgendwie nix zu sehen.
Dann natürlich war diese Absperrung äh auch irgendwie ein Witz. Also das Personal war wieder vorbereitet noch noch äh war man in irgendeiner Form
personell und äh ausrüstungstechnisch passend ausgestattet und äh dann gab's ja noch so Sachen wie das in dem Moment, als dann die Scheiße
richtig am Hochkochen war, ist ja dann eben Rufe gab, hier Nationalgarde, äh reinholen, aber das halt dann der Präsident eben deren Einsatz,
nicht freigegeben hat und äh es dann letzten Endes vom von diesem Mike Pents.
Gemacht werden muss, wenn's schon überhaupt eine absurde Situation, dass man auf einmal feststellt, dass ausgerechnet Mike Pents auf einmal ein paar richtige Dinge tut
Also nicht viele, aber ein Paar, ja, äh das heißt, das ist einfach an mehreren Stellen entweder bewusst,
oder ebenso mit äh Laissi Fair oder ich mache jetzt hier erstmal nix. Ähm unterstützt worden und das sieht man ja auch daran, dass eben.
Die Unterstützer auch teilweise auf die Polizisten eingeredet haben. So und hier, wir sind da irgendwie mit euch und ihr müsst euch äh ihr müsst euch uns anschließen
haben sich natürlich nicht alle angeschlossen, aber da ist natürlich Latent muss man einfach diesem ganzen Apparat jetzt äh misstrauen, inwiefern er eben diesen ganzen Quatsch,
mitträgt und man kann nur hoffen, dass sie große Zahlen an Menschen äh verurteilt werden, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt das nicht unbedingt erwarte. Wir werden sehen.
Also das war also man muss natürlich auch sagen, der also schockierendes, schockierendes Vorkommnis, ganz ohne Frage, ja?
War seit Jahren absehbar, dass das so kommen würde. Ja, habe ich ja auch leider schon oft vorhergesagt, wurde da ja,
anfangs noch für, muss ich mich ja noch für verarschen lassen, so ungefähr. Ähm aber ich denke, jetzt ist wirklich,
vielen klar, was, was hier das das Problem ist und es passiert aber auch, möchte ich sagen, ähm.
Punkt, dass jetzt, sage ich mal, aus der, was ich vor ein paar Sendungen auch vermutet hatte.
Es gab ja eine Reihe an republikanischen Senatoren, die den ganzen Scheiß noch mit angeheizt haben. Und das waren nicht wenige. Und jetzt, jetzt ist der Moment, wo sie sagen, okay,
hier ist die Grenze, hier machen wir nicht mehr weiter, ne. Jetzt gibt's irgendwie hier mit ähm,
distanziert sich langsam von Trump. Ja, jetzt jetzt,
haben sie wirklich auch alles aus dem rausgequetscht, was sie brauchen und können sich im Prinzip, haben sie das,
Phänomen in die Geschichtsbücher geschrieben an dieser Wahl gab es Zweifel, ja? Und sie können jetzt zwar sagen, ja hier die die Randalierer und so, die,
sagen wir das ist nicht gut, ne? Aber sie haben auf jeden Fall an alle, die in in alle hier ne die Erinnerung reingepflanzt so
irgendwas mit der Wahl stimmte da nicht und es gab Ausschreitungen und so. Und das ist genau in deren in deren Partei
Interesse. Jetzt natürlich ist Trump wirklich toxisch und man muss sich von dem distanzieren und dann hast du ja auch irgendwelche solche Leute, die dann irgendwie weißt du
am achten Januar zwölf Tage vor Ende der Administration ihren Rücks ihren Rücktritt einreichen, ne. Äh was dann auch mit der kleinen, kleinen äh Ratte auf dem sinkenden Schiff äh
gestempelt wird so, ne? Also das ist ja wirklich ähm es ist auch so auf eine Weise so so dramatisch durchschaubar.
Ja und vor allem entziehen sie sich dadurch ja dann wiederum der nächsten Entscheidung, äh ihnen vielleicht noch auf den letzten Metern abzusetzen über dieses äh, was ja
quasi sie in die Lage versetzen würde, festzustellen, dass er so mental nicht ganz stabil ist und dann doch vielleicht mal abgesetzt werden sollte. Das wäre der der schnelle Weg, den sie auch nicht bereit sind zu gehen
weil sie halt entweder einfach äh entweder sind sie total korrupt das gilt wahrscheinlich für die meisten oder.
Und oder sie haben einfach mega Schiss, dass wenn sie sich jetzt auch noch zu diesem Zeitpunkt gegen Trump stellen, dass sie dann eben diese Horden bei sich im Hinterhof sehen.
Einige schon zugegeben.
Oh Mann, du äh aber ich wollte noch ganz kurz sagen, es gibt natürlich, also für das Internet war das ein eine großartige.
Ein großartiger Meme Kristallisierungspunkt, ja? Also so Feststellung wie am Ende haben die Republikaner.
Die Präsidentschaft, den Senat und das Haus verloren? Der Bastard hat's tatsächlich geschafft, finde ich sehr schön.
Mhm. Ja, das stimmt.
Oder äh so ähm After todays Event, Mexiko heißt die Seite.
Mein mein Lieblings mein Lieblingstyp war allerdings derjenige mit der also er rennt da durch diese durch diesen Protest mit einer großen Trump-Fahne.
Und da drunter hat er die Fahne von Georgia hängen.
Ja? Und die die Flagge von Georgia war eben die erste, die kommt, wenn man Flagge von Georgia googelt, ja? Und man muss halt wissen, dass es ein Land namens Georgien gibt.
Wo man sich.
Die dann da unter Georgischer Flagge den Protest hinweist. Oh ja und dann haben wir natürlich irgendwie Elizabeth aus Noxwell, das ist natürlich das ist ja quasi Diana aus Kassel von ähm von Washington, ja.
Die mit der Zwiebel im Handtuch.
Wo irgendwie über die Zwiebel nachgedacht wird, aber die eben vor allem sich beschwert, dass sie das das wie sie bei der Revolution hier behandelt wurde, ne, also dass da war sie mit ihrem einfach so.
Empört, empört.
Guten Tag, ich ich habe doch ja ich habe doch eine Revolution bestellt. Wieso werde ich hier nicht ordentlich bedient?
Ähm also da da dann dieser dieser ähm ich habe vergessen immer den Namen Alex Alberttidi da was, dieser Schamane da.
Ach so, der Typ, der mit der Pelzmütze, ja.
Der auf allen Bildern drauf ist, ne. Ja ja, der hat ja ähm der ist auch sehr lustig. Also für fürs Internet eigentlich ein guter Tag.
Ja, das Internet hatte vor allem insofern viel, als dass natürlich dann viele Leute auch angefangen haben, innerhalb äh kürzester Zeit auch Twitter diese Leute zu recherchieren.
Und Fotos, Videos zu veröffentlichen und dann ebenso herauszufinden, wer um welche Person es sich denn hier handelt, ne? Teilweise mit schnellen Folgen, dass die Leute dann eine null Komma nix ihren Job los äh waren und dann eben auch
FBI verhaftet wurde.
Teilweise geht es auch noch an, weil ja auch Leute dabei waren, die jetzt eben nicht so in diese äh unmittelbare Trottelkategorie
reinfallen und ich denk das war auch ein Problem am Anfang, dass man gesagt hat, sah OK, das war jetzt hier einfach nur irgendwelche die da durchmarschiert sind und äh
Man konnte sich wunderbar darüber lustig machen, wie sie dann beim Marsch,
sich dann immer noch innerhalb dieser äh rot mit so Kordeln abgesperrten äh Wege äh bewegten, ja und irgendwie Fotos machten, wie so Touristen. Aber es gab ja auch durchaus äh,
extrem gut äh geradezu militärisch ausgerüstete Personen mit Rucksack, mit Waffen, mit Bomben, mit
äh taktisch ein Gier aller Art und die halt auch äh sag mal, auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise sich durch dieses Gebäude bewegt haben.
Die schon wussten, was sie taten, also die entweder generell in dem Feld,
fähig sind oder eben vielleicht und liegt ja auch nah, auch für das Vorgehen innerhalb des Hauses, einen Plan hatten, ne? Und
meine, wenn da Leute irgendwie Geigen hochziehen und sie irgendwie alle hängen, my pilse äh rufen
Und dann äh laufen die da durch die Gänge. Wenn man sich nicht vorstellen, was passiert, wenn sie dann irgendwie Mike Pence auch treffen oder Nancy Pelosi oder AOC oder wen auch immer, also das ist war alles extrem gefährlich schon und das muss man auch sehen.
Und das wird das wird halt auch bleiben, ja? Also was sich da jetzt gezeigt hat, ist eine Radikalisierung, die bleibt.
Ähnlich wie das übrigens ähm in Deutschland ja auch zu befürchten steht mit den mit den Schiefdenkern und so.
Ähm und den und so. Fand ich übrigens aber auch sehr schön, wo wir gerade an die schief Denker denken. Eine auch eine sehr schöne Meldung fand ich Nothilfe, Doppelpunkt Deutschland entsendet zwei Polizisten, um das Kapitol zu schützen.
Was? Rechts.
Fand ich, äh fand ich auch sehr schön.
Äh na ja, weil ja in Deutschland dieser Reichstagssturm ist es ne, der den äh der da den die Schief Denker ange ähm,
haben als dann Donald Trump und Putin schon im Anflug waren, um das deutsche Reich zu befreien, ne. Da sind die ja auch auf die Treppe vom Reichstag hochgerannt und wurden da von zwei, drei Polizisten weggekl,
äh oder noch nie mal weggeklopft, sondern einfach nur zurückgehalten. Ähm.
Ja, sowas hätte äh den den USA in der Situation auch helfen können. Also.
Warum besprechen wir das in Logbuch Netzpolitik? Erstens, klar, es hat ähm hatte netzpolitische Konsequenzen und ich denke auch, dass sich hier wirklich.
Von vielen nicht erwartete extrem dunkle Seite der ganzen Verinternetung zeigt. Und ich habe das hier schon oft gesagt, aber als das vor.
Sagen wir mal grob zwanzig Jahren oder über zwanzig Jahren losging mit diesem Internet, gab es einfach bei sehr vielen oder es herrschte vor.
Die generelle Überzeugung oder die generelle Optimismus,
dass es etwas Gutes ist, wenn mehr Menschen Zugang zur Öffentlichkeit haben und wenn mehr Menschen,
wenn wenn mehr Menschen Einsicht haben, mehr Menschen miteinander kommunizieren, daraus wurde dann leider konsumieren, aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema und wenn mehr Transparenz international herrscht. Und.
Es galt es war die generelle Überzeugung, dass das zur Völkerverständigung und zur Demokratisierung,
ein nennenswerter Beitrag wäre mit diesem Internet. Und es wurde nicht es wurden wahrscheinlich von vielen zunächst bestimmte.
Tendenzen unterschätzt einmal diese Tendenz zur ja.
Kapitalisierung, Marktisierung, Monetarisierung des Netzes, dass das eben nicht einfach nur dieser,
ja Liberale, Libertäre Raum bleibt, in dem man sich irgendwie bewegt, sondern dass das Ding halt egal, was man da macht, kommerziellen Interessen,
unterworfen wird.
Und zweitens, dass bei aller Transparenz ist dann eben Menschen gibt, die sich ja in irgendwelchen Filterblasen vergraben und irgendwelche Rabbit Holes hinunter steigen und da echt.
Tatsächliche Parallelrealitäten sich zusammenbauen. Und dass sich das nicht nur in irgendwelchen.
Internetforen manifestiert, sondern tatsächlich auch in ja, gewaltsamen ähm Aufständen.
Von völligen Personen äh haben wir jetzt gesehen. Und spätestens jetzt sollte allen klar sein, dass das ein richtig ernstzunehmendes Problem ist, für das wir als Gesellschaft.
Ten überhaupt nicht gewappnet sind. Und damit werden wir dann jetzt hier bei dem Thema die Plattformen.
Haben reagiert und jetzt auf verschiedene auf verschiedene Weisen
Donald Trump gesperrt. Ich habe heute nochmal äh glaube ich heute Morgen gehört, dass YouTube ihn jetzt nochmal für eine Woche gesperrt hat
sein sein YouTube-Kanal, also der kann nix Neues posten, aber die alten Sachen bleiben bestehen. Twitter hat den Account gelöscht.
Ihren besten Kunden und ähm.
Facebook hatte Facebook habe ich nicht so verfolgt, aber da ist, glaube ich, auch eine Sperre oder eine Löschung erfolgt, ne. Und.
Dazu muss man jetzt mal vielleicht kurz die diese Diskussion nochmal in Anführungszeichen historisch betrachten. Donald Trump verstößt ja seit vielen Jahren,
regelmäßig gegen die Community Guidelines von Twitter. Also er twittert regelmäßig Dinge.
Die ähm die Nutzungsbedingungen von Twitter verletzen und geahndet werden müssten,
Unter anderem irgendwie wenn er Nordkorea mit einem Atomkrieg droht und was er da nicht alles so gemacht hat, auch wie er sich abfällig über ähm Reporterinnen und so geäußert hat. Die Liste ist sehr lang. Und Twitter hat sich,
auf die Position begeben, die ich auch als Argument schon so ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann zu sagen so, nun.
Das ist eben nicht irgendjemand, sondern das ist der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten. Und wenn der.
Sagt, dann können wir das flecken, aber wir können es nicht löschen. Es ist ja auch für die Transparenz notwendig, den Menschen.
Verhalten auch zu präsentieren, ja? Und es ist ja nun mal so, dass ich auch
zumindest äh einundfünfzig Prozent der Amerikanerinnen darüber aufregen und es ist für die auch wichtig ist, dieses asoziale Verhalten ihres äh Staatsoberhauptes zu sehen,
Und dann haben sie, ich glaube, erst vor einem Jahr oder vielleicht etwas über einem Jahr begonnen, wenigstens.
Wenn er falsche Tatsachenbehauptungen aufgestellt hat, diese zu flecken. Allerdings sehr ähm zaghaft.
Ja, wenn er dann irgendwie mal wieder anfangt, anfing, von Wahlbetrug zu schreiben, haben sie dann so einen Fleck drangemacht, so die Behauptung eines Wahlbetruges ist umstritten.
Ja und so, ja natürlich, also umstritten ist es, klar, da streiten sich ja die Leute, das merkt ja jeder. Ähm es war also immer noch sehr, sehr zaghaft. Und.
Also gesagt, würden wir das löschen, löschen, dann würden wir eine notwendige Diskussion seiner Worte verhindern. Mitte zwanzig neunzehn kam das mit dem Labelling von Regelverstößen und Unwahrheiten. Und ne, also relativ lange haben die den einfach gewähren lassen.
Und jetzt haben sie gesagt, okay, jetzt sperren wir, wir löschen den Account unwiderruflich.
Und zwar weil das Risiko besteht, dass der zu weiteren Gewalttaten.
Aufruft oder beiträgt oder dazu führt.
Und jetzt ist natürlich das Geschrei groß andererseits, dass man sagt, okay, krass, das war letztendlich eine Entscheidung nach der, ja, mehr oder weniger Willkür von am Ende Jackdosy.
Der dann eben sagen kann oder bei Facebook dann Mark Zuckerberg, die sagen, okay, jetzt reicht's, jetzt machen wir, jetzt machen wir Schluss. Und so notwendig und richtig, dass in diesem einen konkreten Fall auf jeden Fall war und es wäre wahrscheinlich.
Potenziell wäre uns vielleicht viel erspart geblieben, wenn dir das früher gemacht hätten, könnte man argumentieren.
Es gibt zumindest wenige, die meines Erachtens dafür argumentieren, dass Donald Trump unbedingt sein Twitter-Account behalten sollte, aber das.
Das ist, wie es dazu kam und wie es passiert ist, ist halt enorm problematisch, weil letztendlich,
hat sich hier gezeigt, dass ein Privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen wie Twitter dem Präsidenten der USA den Account löscht,
und der nichts dagegen tun kann. Und der letztendlich vollständig an deren Gnade hing. Dann gibt es natürlich erstmal, sage ich mal, von den weniger informierten, dann den Punkt, ja, Meinungsfreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit hin und her, ja?
Da muss man eine bittere Wahrheit benennen, so dass.
Also es gibt zwei Perspektiven. Erstens, natürlich kannst du deine Meinung sagen, du hast aber keinen Anspruch darauf, dass dass andere sich die unbedingt anhören oder dir darauf antworten. Und zweitens.
Ist es nun mal so, wenn du sagst, dein dein du verlegst dein Diskussionsforum der Politik.
In den in den privaten Bereich eines Unternehmens, wo es letztendlich darum geht,
dass dieses Unternehmen mehr Nutzerinnen findet und bessere Werbung verkauft und neue äh und einen Aktienkurs betreut,
dann unterliegst du da nicht irgendwie den Regeln, was weiß ich, der Diaspora, sondern da unterliegst du den Regeln dieses Unternehmens. Und wenn die sagen, hier wird ab heute nicht mehr über Politik diskutiert, dann ist das so.
Und das ist eine, das ist natürlich auch leider genau das Problem und das das sind das verstehen die Leute jetzt plötzlich, ne. Haben sie aber die letzten zwanzig Jahre oder fünfzehn Jahre, wie Facebook da äh rangewachsen ist und Twitter irgendwie nicht gesehen.
Und schreien Zensur.
Jetzt schreien sie Zensur. Äh also ich es ist halt.
Ich will da jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass ich die die Lösung hätte, ne. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass ich vermutlich.
Also man muss ja überlegen, wenn man jetzt Jack Dorsy ist, ne, also der CEO von Twitter.
Dann überlegst du dir natürlich schon, wenn der, wenn der Präsident der USA da dreimal am Tag dafür sorgt oder dreimal die Woche dafür sorgt.
Dass deine Plattform irgendwie in den Medien ist.
Ja und gesagt wird hier der Präsident hat getwittert, der Präsident hat getwittert dann hat das natürlich durchaus ein,
einen Effekt für den für deinen Aktienkurs, für deine Nutzungszahlen und für die Relevanz deiner Plattform. Äh Twitter-Aktie ist natürlich auch gefallen, nachdem die den gelöscht haben, ne?
Wobei jetzt die Frage ist, das kann auch einfach daran liegen, dass irgendwelche Trading Algorithmen gesehen haben, aha, hier gibt's negative Nachrichten und es steht Twitter mit dabei.
Ja, es tritt sich fest.
Ja, ja, das, also das wird schon schon wieder gehen, ne, aber.
Ich denke, was das Problem ist, dass hier kein oder was das Problem ist, dass es hier kein kein Prozess gibt und dass die Regeln, die für Donald Trump gegolten haben, immer eine irgendwie eine Willkür hatten,
und diese diese Willkür war nirgendwo. Ähm so verankert, dass sie für alle.
Gleich ist. Und jetzt sagen natürlich die Leute, ah ja klar, wenn äh da werden sich aber jetzt bestimmte Staaten freuen, dass das, dass Twitter sogar dem Präsidenten löschen kann, dann kann man ja auch äh viele andere löschen. Also ich find's.
Äh mir fällt mir fällt zumindest auch keine bessere Lösung ein, muss ich sagen. Ne, ist also klar, man will eine man will eine Regelung haben, die irgendwie national oder international ist.
Und dann stellt sich wieder die Frage, naja wie will jetzt ein Nationalstaat auf einmal darüber entscheiden, dass jemand hier eine weltweite Reichweite hat oder nicht hat?
Es scheint mir echt ein ungelöstes Problem zu sein. Vielleicht fehlt mir da auch die die Kreativität. Aber ich sehe irgendwie nicht, wie das.
Also man sieht das Defizit, mir leuchtet das auch ein, aber ich sehe auch irgendwie nicht, wie es besser hätte sein können.
Ja, also es ist jetzt.
Fällt dir was ein. Ich weiß, du sagst natürlich also du findest natürlich wir sind ja alle froh, dass der Trump-Account jetzt endlich weg ist. Oder oder oder wünscht du ihn dir zurück.
Nee, auf keinen Fall. Also, ich meine äh das das hätte meiner Meinung nach auch schon früher passieren können, auch wenn ich natürlich sehe, wie schwierig das ist,
in einer konkreten Situation, insbesondere jetzt für die Führer kapitalistischer Unternehmen, hier die richtigen Handlungen zu machen, weil man muss ja immer fragen, wem sind sie denn jetzt eigentlich am meisten verpflichtet?
Ja? Sind sie äh dem,
ihren eigenen Zielen und Wünschen, was dieses Unternehmen vielleicht mal sein soll äh verpflichtet, sind sie ihren
Aktien äh Eigentümern, den Miteigentümern des Unternehmens, den Shareholdern
verpflichtet, ja, sie sind natürlich dem Gesetz gegenüber verpflichtet, aber dann ist eben auch noch die Frage, inwiefern spielt gesellschaftliche Verantwortung hier eine Rolle? Und ich möchte nicht in der äh Rolle von von Jack Dorsy gewesen
sein, auch jetzt nicht sein. Äh das permanent miteinander abzuwägen. Ich meine, das geht ja auch nicht erst seit,
Seit Trump so, ich meine, wir hatten das mit mit Gamergate, was man, glaube ich, im Rückblick äh sehr wohl mal so ein bisschen als diesen Urknall dieses ganzen Wahnsinns äh,
bezeichnen kann, ja, wo dieses Abwägen von äh Meinungsfreiheit versus Harresmond äh sich im Prinzip ja schon wunderbar gezeigt hat und das Ganze im Prinzip so eine Art Testlauf war für diese ganze Trump-Ära.
Und äh Stück für Stück sind wir dann quasi auch als Gesellschaft mitgewachsen. Erstmal überhaupt dieses,
Auswirkungen als solche zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, ja, was vorhin schon angedeutet hat, so. Früher dachten wir immer so, naja, wenn alle mehr mitreden können, dann haben wir mehr Demokratie und blühende Landschaften so.
Was sicherlich auch ein Aspekt
ist, dieser ganzen Entwicklung, aber eben beileibe nicht der einzige, sondern auf einmal siehst du eben diesen globalen Stammtisch, der äh sich seine eigene Echokammer baut und wenn halt irgendein Luni auch nur eine andere Person auf einmal auf dem Planeten wahrnimmt, die den gleichen Scheiß,
dann verstärken die sich dann halt eben enorm. Und das hat dann eben den Effekt, dass äh äh wenn du dann so eine tumpe Masse hast, die irgendwie jeden Scheiß glaubst, dass du natürlich auch sofort Leute gibt, die sagen,
prima, äh den brauche ich jetzt nur einfach nur eine ganze Menge Scheiße einzutüten, dann glauben die das alle und darauf kann ich meine Macht äh aufbauen. Das ist.
Im Prinzip, dass wir die Nazis groß geworden sind und das ist genau das,
was Trump gesagt hat und deswegen haben wir eigentlich ja auch von Anfang an, ich glaube, wir haben's relativ klar benannt als Tramp an die Macht kam, haben wir äh klar benannt, so, okay, das ist jetzt einfach mal so der Faschismus in neuem Gewande,
dahaben sich ja einige drüber aufgeregt. Vor allem die Junge Union, die war ja sehr hoffnungsfroh. So und äh jetzt haben wir den den Salat. Und natürlich müssen wir jetzt einen Weg finden, wie wir diesen öffentlichen Diskurs regeln,
Wenn er nicht geregelt wird, dann passiert genau das. Das ist halt einfach, es läuft dann einfach frei
wer da jetzt wo, wann äh äh rechtliche Systeme schaffen muss oder inwiefern sowas nur auf gesellschaftlichen Druck erfolgen kann
Das ist äh sicherlich der Inhalt einer noch lange zu führenden intensiv zu führenden gesellschaftlichen Debatte, nicht nur in den USA, sondern natürlich auch bei uns.
Und äh ich denke nicht, dass man jetzt hier auch mit den
klassischen Maximalforderungen äh viel erreichen kann, sondern das ist einfach ein ein Kompromiss, den man da finden muss.
Ne, also so weder dieses
darf keine Zensur geben, Meinungsfreiheit über alles und so weiter, das funktioniert halt genauso wenig wie eben dieser andere Ansatz mit. Alles muss jetzt hier doppelt gecheckt und überprüft werden und alles muss irgendwie sanktioniert werden,
ja, was wir stellenweise auch schon haben. Das sind alles keine einfachen Wege. Also,
deswegen rotieren wir da, glaube ich, auch beide so ein bisschen hin und her, eben weil es da keine einfachen Antworten gibt.
Ich mache mal eine eine, ich mache mal eine eine Kontroverse, ein Schritt, ja? Ich würde vermutlich, je länger ich darüber nachgedacht habe, eigentlich sagen, ja, ich meine.
Es ist klar, du kannst du willst so viel wie möglich Regeln, durch durch Regeln, die für alle gleich sind, ne? Und du gerätst irgendwo an die Grenzen dieser Regeln. Und ich habe tatsächlich für dieses Argument,
von Twitter. Ähm hier, das ist der Präsident leider, aufgrund der Bedeutsamkeit seiner Worte gelten hier,
tatsächlich andere Regeln, ja,
weil, ne, das ist nicht irgendein Penner aus dem Internet, sondern halt ein Penner aus dem Internet, der Präsident geworden ist. Und deswegen müssen wir den ähm,
sich äußern lassen, ne? Müssen wir das hier auch äh aufgrund der historischen Bedeutsamkeit stehen lassen. Ähm.
Jetzt ist es so, du kannst natürlich nicht, also jede Regel braucht irgendwie ihren Handlungsspielraum und in dem Handlungsspielraum muss dann letztendlich ja so sowas wie, wenn ich jetzt mal ganz,
blöd zu der kategorische Imperativ gelten. Ja, also auch in dem was nicht schon geschrieben steht in deinem Handlungsspielraum, musst du trotzdem,
darfst du trotzdem keine Ungleichheit zeigen, keine Diskriminierung zeigen und du musst stets so handeln, dass es auch die Maxime deines Handelns gleichzeitig Grundlage eines Gesetzes sein könnte. Und.
Ich würde vorsichtig vermuten, auch wenn ich um meiner eigenen,
psychischen Gesundheitswillen irgendwann aufgehört habe, Donald Trump zu folgen oder das regelmäßig zu lesen, was der twittert. Ich würde vorsichtig sagen, dass Twitter da.
Wahrscheinlich doch richtig agiert hat. Ähm und zwar zu sagen, so okay, ne, alles noch irgendwie hier Äußerungen und so, aber okay, jetzt
haben wir gesehen, das führt zu gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzungen dieser Mensch lügt nachvollziehbar ähm und ähm
heizt diese Gewalt an und da müssen wir jetzt ein ein Ende ziehen und das ist eben auch jetzt und natürlich kommt das zu einem Unzeitpunkt, weil,
Ist jetzt halt ein paar also nur noch wenige Tage sind bis man den eh los ist und es dann natürlich in dem Moment muss man natürlich auch sagen einerseits ist er in dem Moment wieder einfach nur irgendein Penner im Internet und nicht mehr der äh Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten,
ja
Andererseits ist es dann natürlich besonders krass, wenn dieser ganz normale Mensch in Anführungszeichen von allen Plattformen geworfen wurde und nun.
Kaum Möglichkeiten hat,
kaum mehr Möglichkeiten hat, sich gehört zu verschaffen. Das war ja so ein bisschen auch die, also die andere Argumentation ist ja, entschuldige mal, ne. Du bist der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten. Du hast den Press-Brief-Room, du hast eine ähm eine Reihe von Sprecherinnen und
Schreiberin, du bist der eine Mensch auf dieser Welt, der nie Schwierigkeiten hat, sich äh Gehör zu verschaffen in der Öffentlichkeit, ne.
Und insofern würde ich fast sehr vorsichtig sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es anders gemacht hätte.
Weil es geht ja jetzt auch nicht nur um Trams Account. Jetzt grade in dieser Woche sind, glaube ich, nochmal so siebzigtausend äh,
QR-Norn äh verbreitende Bots oder reale Accounts äh veröffentlicht worden. Und du hast ja tonnenweise solche,
republikanischen und sonst wie rechtsgerichteten Nazi-Accounts, die einfach die ganze Zeit da am rumtönen war und
da hätte man natürlich auch schon konsequent dagegen vorgehen können, beziehungsweise,
kann ich das natürlich gar nicht genau benennen, weil unter Umständen wurde ja das auch im großen Maße getan. Also es wird ja am laufenden Meter irgendwie,
Bereinigung stattgefunden. Klare Statistiken darüber kenne ich nicht, weiß ich auch nicht, ob die so im Detail veröffentlicht werden, ne? Und dann,
neben der öffentlichen Hölle von Twitter, hast du natürlich dann auch noch so diese ganzen geschlossenen Höllen, wie äh zum Beispiel auf Facebook
wo ihr dann einfach sehr viel Aktivität in geschlossenen Gruppen stattfindet, et cetera
ohne dass das eben so ohne weiteres mit einer URL und einem Link äh nachzuschlagen wäre. Ne, von den ganzen Secure Messengern, Telegram und so weiter mal ganz abgesehen.
Du meinst die ganzen Secure Messenger und Telegram.
Genau.
Womit wir jetzt äh auch äh bei dem Punkt sind, immer was dann passiert, ja, wenn wenn.
Sagen wir mal eine. Hier kann man ja schon sagen, erstens eine Reichweitenstarke Person und zweitens eine gesellschaftliche Strömung, in dem Falle die ähm.
Verschwörungsfantasten.
Ähm von solchen Plattformen runtergeballert werden, dann freut sich der Dritte, ja? Also es gibt ja durchaus, es ist ja nicht so, als hätte es nicht immer wieder Plattformen gegeben,
und es gibt auch zu jedem gegebenen Zeitpunkt immer eine, die sich rühmt, ähm.
Ja, so die letzte Bastion der Meinungsfreiheit zu sein, ne? Sei das Fortschänen, sei das AChen, sei das Aidcoon ähm und wie sie alle heißen und Gap und eben hier dieses ähm,
System. Und da hat dann, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, Donald Trump gesagt, da gehen wir jetzt hin, ne. Und nee, er hat gesagt, er will seine eigene Plattform machen, ne.
Was auch immer er damit meint, aber redet er, glaube ich, eher vom Fernsehsender.
Zum Glück wird ja für nichts mehr Investoren finden und hat selber keine Kohle, insofern kann er von mir aus so viel reden wie er möchte. Ähm auf jeden Fall.
Er hat, er hat schon noch einen Wert für diese Hardcore äh radikalisierten, ne? Er ist sozusagen qua seines ikonenhaften Status, den er jetzt in dieser Szene aufgebaut hat
natürlich auch über seine offenen Bankkredite hinweg
irgendwo ähm einen Wert und das wird er sicherlich auch irgendwie Cashew. Trotzdem äh aber ist eine andere Diskussion wird da sicherlich
in einige finanzielle Probleme geraten in der nächsten Zeit und wenn sein Stern sinkt, dann ist natürlich auch sein Wiederverkaufswert an der Stelle äh ein wenig
abgesunken.
Das ist natürlich insbesondere, also das glaube ich auch, dass
ihm vielleicht auch selber klar werden wird, dass spätestens mit diesem Kapitolsturm
Das hat ihnen eine ganze Menge Werbeverträge gekostet, ja? Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass noch irgendein noch so großer Idiot irgendwo auf der Welt ein Trump-Hotel bauen will oder einen Trump-Vodka äh vermarkten möchte.
Also das wird äh.
Da hat sich der Wert auf jeden Fall äh hoffentlich geschmälert. Okay, aber in diesem Fall, dass das soziale Netzwerk, was jetzt der heiße Scheiß für Verschwörungsmytika wurde und über das überall berichtet wurde, war eben dieses.
Pala, oder nicht?
Pala, äh was eigentlich ein ganz ähm putziger Name ist, wenn man mal so die,
Bedeutungen rausliest, die sich jetzt unmittelbar äh drängen, nicht also auf der einen Seite klingt es auf Englisch wie Pala, also Palo geschrieben, also der Salon, das Wohnzimmer, da wo man so
sitzt und redet, ne? Und parallel auf Französisch, heißt ja auch Reden.
Ähm ja, das äh ich habe da nicht drin rumgeklickt. Ich äh kann ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, wie das aussieht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da irgendwas gesehen hast oder so, äh ob,
so wie so ein Twitter rüberkommt oder oder wie so ein Facebook. Ich vermute mal, es dürfte irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine Mischung aus beidem
sein. Auf jeden Fall ist das so ein bisschen so, dass das Social Media der Rechtsextremen und äh hat sich wohl größter Beliebtheit äh,
erfreut insbesondere bei den Leuten, die diesen Capitols da begleitet haben, denn dort waren wohl extrem viele Leute äh
zumindest wurde also fleißig da hochgeladen und äh Texte gepostet und auch im Vorfeld eben auch schon die ganze Veranstaltung mit organisiert, angekündigt, debattiert, et cetera. Und äh es wurden dann eben auch an dem Tag eine ganze Menge Videos von diesem Capitolsturm auf dieser
Webseite veröffentlicht. Ja und pala ist aber dann relativ schnell auch so ins Fadenkreuz der,
großen Unternehmen geraten, weil es natürlich klar war, alles, was jetzt in irgendeiner Form diesen Kapitols unterstützt hat, ist jetzt erstmal,
gefährdet. So, also alles, alles wird jetzt gerade überprüft und Google und Apple waren dann auch relativ schnell unterwegs und haben halt äh.
Kurzer Vorwarnzeit ähm die Apps aus den Stores rausgeschmissen,
klar, das hat natürlich auch noch ein Webinterface, damit ist so ein System nicht gleich tot, aber es äh schränkt zumindest die Exzesse ein, beziehungsweise kann man dann zumindest Apple und Google nicht mehr vorwerfen,
dass sie das unterstützen. Auch hier kann man sich fragen, warum jetzt erst, ne? Gut, aber,
Egal, ist halt äh jetzt so, ne. Also ich meine, auf einmal hat es dann sozusagen den den Bedingungen nicht mehr entsprochen. Also vorher wurde da sozusagen ein Regierungsumsturz geplant. Das ging noch so, aber wenn er es dann auch wirklich noch probiert, na dann ist aber auch jetzt mal wirklich Schluss, ne.
Gut, dann kann man sich jetzt lange drüber äh unterhalten. Ändert nix.
Amazon ist dann auch sehr schnell unterwegs gewesen und hat gesagt, so ja hier, ihr hustet euren Kram ja hier auf Amazon,
Webservices auf unseren AWS-Systemen, ihr entspricht offensichtlich hier nicht mehr unseren ähm rechtlichen Bedingungen, die ihr ja eigentlich unterschrieben habt
und ihr ruft ja hier zu Gewalt auf. Äh also schmeißen wir euch jetzt hier auch mal von unserer Infrastruktur runter und das hat natürlich dann dazu geführt, dass Pala.
Im Prinzip offline gehen musste, weil in dem Moment, wo sie nicht mehr auf Amazon gehostet werden, müssen sie natürlich irgendwas anderes finden und,
Chef von Paula dieser John Matze oder wie der heißt
äh hat ja dann auch schon öffentlich beklagt, dass es etwas schwierig wäre, gerade andere Hooster zu bekommen, weil sie eigentlich nur noch Absagen bekommen, wenn sie irgendwo anfragen, ob sie nicht da ihre Daten drauf schmeißen können.
Außerdem sei ihnen auch gerade sein Anwaltsteam irgendwie abhanden gekommen, weil die jetzt,
alle gerade kein Bock mehr haben in irgendwie rechtlich zu vertreten, dann ist natürlich etwas schwierig gegen Vertragsverletzungen vorzugehen, wenn da noch nicht mal ein Anwalt am Staat hast.
So ist das mit einem Schiff voller Ratten. Ja, das ist ruck zuck.
Rumzuklären, ne.
Ja, also sieht so aus, als ob dieser Laden nicht mehr so richtig äh online äh geht, ne? Was weiß ich, vielleicht finden sie ja noch in Russland irgendwie ein paar Server, aber ob das dann so ihrer Reputation ähm
hilft, das sei mal dahingestellt, so oder so, selbst wenn du jetzt auf einem
Plattform gehst, die so theoretisch äh Amazon kompatible APIs bereitstellt, so ein System
holst du nicht mal eben von heute auf morgen auf eine andere Plattform, weil das einfach so viele Implikationen hat und was der Geier, wie sehr es innerhalb dieses Ladens noch äh sonst irgendwie brennt und wie viele Leute da eben das Schiff auch noch verlassen
weiß man nicht. Eigentliche Frage ist jetzt, was ist denn da abgegangen und dann gab's äh,
einen Twitter-Post von einer vermutlich weiblichen Hockerin äh Donk Unterstrich NB.
Die äh dann äh auf interessanten Wege, den die mir immer noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar ist, wie da gelaufen ist
an äh alle Palaposts äh von diesem sechsten Januar rangekommen ist und nicht nur das, sondern eben auch
Videos, die an dem Tag auf die Plattform hochgeladen wurden,
und die hat sie dann mal äh archiviert und äh öffentlich bereitgestellt zum Download
und besteht halt auch drauf, dass das jetzt sozusagen nicht im eigentlichen Sinne ein Hack war, sondern es macht so den Eindruck, als.
Ungeschützte äh Amazon Buckets, also das sind so diese Datenspeichereinheiten in diesen AWS-Systemen, dass die da halt irgendwie rumlagen, sprich äh
Es heißt, ich finde die Darstellung ein bisschen schwierig, aber irgendwie sind sie sozusagen drauf gekommen, wo liegen denn die Daten eigentlich wirklich? Das ging aus irgendwelchen Pressreliesses äh hervor und dann haben sie halt mal ein bisschen rumgeschaut und sind in irgendeiner Form auf
richtigen Buckets gekommen, die waren dann scheiße konfiguriert und konnten dann halt einfach runtergeladen werden.
Das findest du recht häufig. Also Amazon
oder es ist relativ häufiges Problem, dass Leute ihre äh Datenbanken oder Datenspeicher, die ihr Amazon über S drei bereitstellt,
nicht ordentlich abdichten, ja? Und dass das dass die irgendwie in einer Standardkonfiguration, zu permasiv, zugreifbar sind oder dass sie,
Tokens, die man für den Zugriff braucht in in ihren Code, Heartcode drinstehen haben und den Code auf Gitter haben oder so. Also es ist eine relativ häufig, dass dass ein großer Datenreichtum entsteht,
weil weil jemand halt sich mal schnell was auf Amazon geklickt hat und nicht genau verstanden hat, wie so ein Bucket
Zugriffsgeschützt ist und wie nicht. Wie das genau in dem Fall passiert ist, ich habe mich da auch nicht genau eingelesen. Entscheidend war, es gab eben diese diesen doch
relativ großen Datenreichtum ähm inklusive vieler Daten, die es ermöglichen, die ähm,
Die Autorin dieser Posts irgendwie zu,
identifizieren. Stimmt das eigentlich, dass da auch hier Personalausweis dabei waren? Weil die die irgendwie hochladen mussten oder sowas.
Habe ich gelesen. Also ich fand die.
Ich habe verschiedene Twitter-Srits mir durchgelesen. Es gibt jetzt nicht so einen Blogpost, wo das irgendwie alles drin steht und auch so die Recherchen sind noch ein bisschen widersprüchlich. Da bin ich auch da
für klärende Kommentare, aber derzeit macht es den Eindruck, dass im Prinzip es dann anderen Leuten
die dann alle losgeschickt wurden. Also es wurde ja dann für diesen Download wurden irgendwie so docker Images noch äh verteilt
die dann quasi Distribute liefen, das heißt, von allen Ecken und Enden wurden irgendwie diese Daten runtergeladen. Das sind
äh Therapies an Daten, also ich habe irgendwas von von sechs bis vierzehn Terabytes gelesen
und angeblich sei das dann auch schon so neunundneunzig Komma neun Prozent aller Posts und natürlich eben auch dieser ganzen RAW Upload-Videos. Und ich habe das auch gelesen, kann ich dir jetzt aber nicht wirklich
tätigen, dass eben auch,
zur Autorisierung des Accounts, dann die Leute eben auch noch so ihre Führerscheine hochgeladen haben, das ist ja dann quasi der in USA und damit sich sozusagen auch gleich äh bestätigt haben. Ja hier ich,
bin es, ich habe hier die Revolution einleiten wollen. Hier ist meine Adresse und äh alles Mögliche. Auf jeden Fall
Füllhorn für Recherche und ein Füllhorn natürlich auch für Strafverfolgung, so denn äh das.
Rechtssystem der USA jetzt hier auch eine Strafverfolgung wirklich einleitet. Man weiß ja nicht, wie viel Unterstützer dieser ganzen Maßnahme
in ähm im Strafverfolgungsbereich jetzt hier noch tatsächlich existieren. Tatsache ist, Parla ist weg.
Die Daten scheinen da zu sein,
und man hat einfach jetzt hier wunderbares Material, weil natürlich diese ganzen hochgeladenen Videos jetzt nicht sozusagen so sind, wie man sie ja dann im Web sehen würde, sondern dass die ganzen RAW Data. Also mit den ganzen Metadaten,
GPS Koordinaten et cetera, um die genauen Uhrzeiten. Et cetera PP.
Ähm vielleicht kurz also der CEO von Pala sagt, dass da ähm Führerscheins abhanden gekommen sein wäre eine Fehlinformation. Ich hab's bisher, also.
Ja gut, ich meine, was der jetzt behauptet, das kann auch, das kann er auch natürlich alles behaupten, um da seine eigenen äh äh.
Zitiere ich das nochmal so.
Wie gesagt, also ich habe alles Mögliche gelesen und man wird es am Ende feststellen, Tatsache ist, es gibt Tonnen an Daten
und vor allem, es gab ja auch schon so Maps, wo sie dann irgendwie die einzelnen Videos, die da hochgeladen wurden, dann so geteckt haben und dann kleine Punkte, um dieses Capitol herum, also da kriegst du ein sehr gutes Bewegungsbild
außerdem, das kommt ja noch dazu
ist es so, dass das Kapitol aus Sicherheits- und vielleicht auch aus Kapazitätsgründen, aber ich denke vor allem aus Sicherheitsgrenzen, natürlich eigene Mobilfunk Zellen betreibt
die quasi jeden, der sich da mit seinem Mobiltelefon nähert
äh übernehmen, ja, das ist das normale äh Roaming, du gehst einfach in diesen Bereich, die Zelle übernimmt und dort wird aber natürlich dann alles gelockt, das heißt, die haben die ganzen Geräte, IDs, mindestens,
von den äh Leuten, die dort irgendwas äh äh verschickt haben,
cetera, keine Ahnung, was da alles noch im Einzelnen erhoben werden äh kann oder was er erhoben wird.
Ist sehr simpel, also du hast halt die die IMEI
ähm was man jetzt übersetzen kann im im weitesten Sinne in die Meckadresse deiner drei G, vier G fünf G Schnittstelle, die ist äh einzigartig pro Gerät.
Theoretisch auch Fehlern, Bluetooth kannst du auch noch mit äh loggen natürlich.
Kannste machen, da hast du aber natürlich äh diese Mac Adresse im Wege, aber ähm wenn die da tatsächlich ihr eigenes Netz betreiben, ja, dann haben sie,
schon die Information, die jetzt einer staatlichen Organisation es natürlich auch ermöglichen, auf andere Netz, also auf die,
zumindest landeseigene Netzbetreiber zuzugehen und zu sagen, so hier die IMEI.
Ähm oder diese im Sie, ja? Ähm wir wollen wissen, wer das ist, äh wäre jetzt in Deutschland äh mit einer Bestandsdatenauskunft überhaupt kein Problem. Also man kann das eigentlich übersetzen in eine Funkzellenabfrage,
was sie die Informationen, die sie da gewinnen und ähm also der technische Hintergrund ist jetzt nicht, nicht nennenswert äh.
Anders, ja, auch wenn sie die jetzt selber betreiben. Sie werden sicherlich die Möglichkeit haben, alle Personen, die dort waren, ähm,
festzustellen. Sie werden aber nicht die Möglichkeit haben,
die so genau zu ordnen, um jetzt äh oder vermutlich nicht unbedingt die Möglichkeit haben, die so genau zu orten, ob die jetzt im Copitol drin waren oder nicht. Es sei denn, sie betreiben dort irgendwie Nano oder Femtozellen, was durchaus auch sein kann.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Relativ großes äh Gebäude ist. Also.
Da darf man gespannt sein, insgesamt glaube ich kann man sagen, mit den Daten, die im Mobilfunknetz liefert erst recht, wenn es dein eigenes ist, plus den äh dieses Pala hatte ja offenbar auch diese Location-Tacking-Funktionalität.
Gibt es da jetzt auf jeden Fall eine erdrückende eine erdrückende Menge Metadaten über jede Person, die da mit dem Mobiltelefon war und äh vielleicht auch noch damit angegeben hat, ja? Und.
Jetzt wird sich natürlich zeigen, wie stark da die Strafverfolgung tatsächlich einsetzt. Ich habe, wir hatten ja vor der Sendung schon kurz darüber gesprochen, ich sehe äh Videos, wo Leute irgendwie am Flughafen,
am Flugzeug gecrasht werden, weil sie auf der No-Fly-Liste sind und mehr oder weniger ihr Name geteckt ist mit, okay, wenn die Person kommt,
hier einmal der der rote Knopf ja und dann werden die halt sofort da an an Ort und Stelle verhaftet und,
beklagen sich, äh dass sie für für ihren Beitrag zur Revolution jetzt auch noch bestraft werden sollen. Ähm.
Andererseits gibt es auch Anzeichen dafür, dass da jetzt keine nennenswerte,
Verfolgung stattfindet. Ich glaube, das ist da noch nicht so ganz entschieden, ne? Das werden wir erst sehen, wie ernst die USA das jetzt meinen oder nicht meinen. Vielleicht meinen sie es auch erst ab dem einundzwanzigsten Januar ernst äh diese Leute,
tatsächlich zu verfolgen.
Das kann gut sein, dass sie jetzt nochmal so eine Woche Headstart haben und dass äh die republikanische Administration alles dran setzt hier die Leute noch irgendwie so frei ziehen zu lassen, aber natürlich haben auch die nur begrenzte Möglichkeiten gegen den Willen äh des FBI vorzugehen
also die haben Möglichkeiten, aber begrenzte Möglichkeiten. Andererseits wissen wir jetzt natürlich auch nicht, inwiefern jetzt die föderale äh Polizei da auch äh durchsetzt ist
Also das,
Sport, der wird uns auf jeden Fall noch eine Weile unterhalten und vielleicht nochmal kurz auf Pala zurückzukommen. Das System ist wahrscheinlich tot, aber es ist sicherlich jetzt nicht das einzige äh äh System, was hier im Fadenkreuz ist. Ich meine, ähm,
Nun muss er im Prinzip äh also es gibt, du hast ja schon ein paar genannt, ich äh,
nicht alle auswendig, aber es gibt ja tonnenweise solche äh rechten oder.
War da noch irgendwie großes Thema.
Ja
Auch schon seit längerem.
Also es gibt da verschiedene Systeme. So ja, die die alle in irgendeiner Form dazu beitragen und in dem Moment, wo eins tot ist, weicht natürlich dann alle gleich wieder ins nächste aus. Andererseits könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sie jetzt vielleicht mal
bisschen mehr darüber nachdenken, was wir da tun, ne? Nee, das kann ich wirklich nicht vorstellen. Also.
Eine schöne Erkenntnis von Pala fand ich übrigens, das sollten wir hier noch erwähnen, ne? Also die haben sich ja als Hord der Meinungsfreiheit da irgendwie zelebriert, ne. Und tatsächlich.
Zeigen halt offenbar Analysen, ähm dass du als neuer Nutzer bei Paarer eigentlich Shadow Band anfängst, also mit anderen Worten, du rufst da so in diese Welt hinein.
Du denkst, du Po.
Aber anderen erstmal nicht großartig angezeigt.
Was ich äh vor vielen Jahren mal auf der Republika ähm vorgeschlagen habe und auch mal programmiert habe für ein Forum. Äh ich habe das damals die Treudrossel genannt. Ähm kann ich vielleicht auch nochmal verlink.
Webforum, ja.
Ja, es war so ein Web Forum, was ich da mal eine Zeit lang betrieben habe.
Ich glaub der Vortrag hieß Refe, Erkenntnisse der empirischen Träuforschung oder sowas, er kann verlink ich nochmal. Jedenfalls quasi wenn du dann neuen Account hast, kriegst du erstmal gar nicht unbedingt Reichweite.
Bis dir Moderatoren,
ausreichend richtige Gesinnung bestätigt haben. Ja, also die haben die haben's quasi, weißt du, die sagen, sie sind der Hort der Meinungsfreiheit und du beginnst da erstmal sofort in der Zensurglocke, ja?
Muss sich da erstmal äh rausnarzen?
Ja? Wenn die irgendwie ausreichend genazt hast, darfst du dann auch äh kommst du auch in den Genuss der der rechtsradikalen Meinungsfreiheit. Das ist natürlich dann auch schon immer sehr äh unterhaltsam. Ich meine, man muss.
Grundsätzlich sagen, dass diese ähm dass diese Experimente in hier ist der Hort der Meinungsfreiheit. Hier kann jeder alles sagen.
In der Regel nach einigen Jahren implodieren, ne? Also sind die besten Beispiele
ne? Das ist dann irgendwann einfach, da haben dann auch diejenigen, die das mal als Exkrement gestartet haben, äh irgendwann nur noch in die Ecke gekotzt und gesagt, ich will das nicht mehr an der Backe haben, ne.
Der ähm ich glaube der Fortschrittgründer hat doch dann, wie heißt das Ding, was der dann gemacht hat? Nein Gag oder so.
Und der Gründer ist inzwischen daraus oder so und wird von wird von seiner ehemaligen.
Gefolgschaft da jetzt auch gemobbt und terrorisiert. Und,
ja, ich bin jetzt auch mal vorsichtig so eventuell drängt sich mir der Eindruck auf, ja, dass wir eben in der westlich in den westlichen Demokratien,
eben doch so viel Meinungsfreiheit noch haben, um die wir, die wir auch jeden Tag verteidigen müssen, nicht, dass man sich da falsch versteht. Aber wir haben.
Doch genug Meinungsfreiheit, dass die jetzt im alltäglichen Leben und in der informierten.
Und Wertbeitragsstiftenden politischen Diskussionen nicht nennenswert gefährdet ist.
Was man auch daran sieht, wie problemlos irgendwelche AfD-Leute
Unsinn reden können. Ja, ohne jegliche Sanktion fürchten zu müssen. Und deswegen sind natürlich solche Dinge so, wo
Hier, hier, hier, hier, im Gegensatz zu der liberalen Demokratie, gibt es hier Meinungsfreiheit, da weißt du dann eben schon, wen du dir da eintrittst, nämlich Leute, die
irgendwie sich auf eine Weise oder mit Inhalten äußern, die.
So weit außerhalb von allem akzeptablen sind, dass sie meinen, dass ihre Meinungsfreiheit irgendwie eingeschnitten würde. Nochmal, ich habe.
Dafür müssen wir jeden Tag kämpfen für diese Meinungsfreiheit, ne? Und ich will nur sagen, der Schein ist eigentlich ganz gut zu gelingen. Na ja.
Na ja, ist ja alles richtig. Ja, Pala ist auf jeden Fall äh Dad und äh das Modell werden wir sicherlich bald äh wiedersehen. Es gibt hier noch genug zu bekämpfen. Let's move on.
Ja, let's move on. Äh okay. Also, WhatsApp hat äh seine Datenschutzbestimmung geändert.
Und ähm sagt, den Nutzerinnen, sie müssen bis zum achten Februar dieser Änderung zustimmen oder können dann WhatsApp nicht mehr nutzen. Das ist natürlich eine großartige Gelegenheit an dieser Stelle, sich einfach mal von WhatsApp zu trennen,
dennoch muss ich sagen, dass die Gemengelage dazu absolut unklar ist, ja. Denn äh schon seit Juli steht in den Datenschutzerklärungen, dass sie bestimmte ähm
dass sie irgendwie eine Mischung der Daten mit Facebook haben.
Also dass sie, nee, Moment, dass sie erstens bei WhatsApp für Freundesvorschläge und personalisierungsfunktion und Werbung diese Daten,
nutzen dürfen. Ja, das das war schon früher. Ähm und jetzt wird irgendwie ähm nur eine komische Änderung vorgenommen, die.
Die nicht so schlimm ist wie die, die schon gemacht wurden. Aber ich spiele noch mal einen Schritt zurück. Tatsache war so, es gab gab ein soziales Netzwerk, das hieß Facebook. Dieses soziale Netzwerk hat zwei fette Konkurrenten gehabt.
Der Zeit. Der eine war Instagram, also haben sie Instagram gekauft und der andere war WhatsApp, also haben sie WhatsApp gekauft. Der Dritte war TikTok,
Diese Diskussion war die, wo Donald Trump halt versucht hat, mehr oder weniger das Unternehmen zu erpressen, äh den die zumindest den US-Markt äh zu verkaufen.
Facebook diese äh WhatsApp und Instagram gekauft hat, haben sie ganz klar versprochen, dass sie diese Dienste vollkommen getrennt,
weiterführen werden. Und das äh Versprechen wurde dann schon wenige.
Wurde dann so im im Jahresrhythmus wird dieses Versprechen irgendwie abgebaut. Äh ich glaube, es war irgendwann zwanzig neunzehn oder so, als angekündigt wurde
Wir haben ja hier Facebook Messenger, WhatsApp und Instagram. Das sind ja drei PM-Funktionen, die wir in unserem Hause haben. Und die werden wir jetzt mal vereinheitlichen, ne, sodass du von WhatsApp an Instagram
und so weiter schicken kannst und das einfach ein einheitliches Ding ist. Damit wir hier nicht mehr drei unterschiedliche Datensilos haben, sondern diese Daten mal zusammenführen können.
Und seither gibt es eben regelmäßig.
Kleine Städtetropfen, wo mit irgendwelchen Datenschutzänderungen diese Daten immer mehr zusammengeführt werden. Und jedes Mal gibt's einen Aufschrei und jedes Mal gibt's dann irgendeine Beschwichtigung
Ja, am Ende steht aber, dass es eben nach und nach langsam passiert. Ich bin im Presseinterview dazu gefragt worden.
Ist das der Dammbruch und darauf habe ich so sinngemäß geantwortet, nee, es gibt hier keinen Dammbruch, der Damm wird einfach langsam zurückgebaut. Ja, und äh genau das, denke ich, ist hier dieser Lami-Taktik, die hier äh,
ähm ja vollführt wird. Und jetzt wurde hatte das die Folge, ja, dass also.
Erstens WhatsApp sagt, ja ja, wir ändern die Datenschutzbedingungen, aber für die Nutzerinnen ändert sich nichts,
ja? Also dann fragt man sich natürlich, warum ändert ihr die dann? Ja, dann haben sie gesagt, ja in Europa gilt aber was anderes und das, was da drin steht, da steht ja nur drin, das was dürfen, aber wir machen's trotzdem nicht,
Ja, dafür brauchst du aber natürlich keine Datenschutzbestimmung zu ändern.
Also maximal unklare Gemengelage führte dazu, dass dein Elon Musk twitterte use signal und ähm Leute massiv äh,
zu Signal und zu Threema gewechselt haben. Und ich würde dazu eigentlich nur eins sagen, ähm.
Es ist sicherlich sinnvoll, sich von WhatsApp zu verabschieden und der, ich möchte an der Stelle einfach nur nochmal sagen, dass es eben.
Nicht eine individuelle Perspektive ist, mit der man darauf blicken muss. Ja, also es kann ja, wenn ich mich jetzt irgendwie bei so einem Facebook-Dienst anmelde, gehe ich eben einen Deal ein und das heißt, dass ich,
Entweder sage ich, ich vertraue Facebook, dass sie mit meinen Daten nichts Schlechtes anstellen oder ich halte meine Daten für so wenig wertvoll,
dass ich sie hergebe, um diesen Dienst Messenger zu bekommen, kostenlos, ja? Also das ist ja die, die Abstimmung, die jede Einzelperson irgendwie in ihrem Kopf trifft,
Aber diese individuelle Perspektive greift zu kurz, denn es geht nicht darum, was man persönlich zu verbergen hat oder nicht, sondern es geht darum, was man durch diese,
ich glaube WhatsApp hat ja über eine Milliarde Nutzer, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ne.
Schon sein, ja.
Ähm sondern es geht um die gesellschaftliche Perspektive, wenn nämlich genug Menschen diesen Deal machen, dann wächst eben dieser Datenschatz des Unternehmens,
und auch die Macht und die Abhängigkeit von diesem Unternehmen. Und das ist ja eben einigen erst klar geworden, bei so bei diesem Cambridge Analytica-Skandal. Ähm.
Man sagte, ach krass, ey, ich habe hier zwanzig Jahre gesagt, ach geil, zielgruppengerichtete Werbung, ich kriege nur noch Werbung für Herrenschuhe, nicht mehr für Damenschuhe, finde ich voll geil.
Und als es dann auf einmal hieß, ja Zielgruppenorientierte, politische Werbung, dann war einer auf einmal, oh mein Gott, die
Atombombe für die Demokratie wurde dann auf einmal allen klar, ne, so ähm hätte man natürlich auch vorher schon
drüber nachdenken können, aber wer solche Unternehmen kritisiert, ist ja ein Datenschützer, ein Aluhutträger und bildet sich ein irgendwas äh,
verbergen zu haben. Und genau das ist es nicht. Das Problem ist, wir nähren damit multinationale Machtzentralen.
Die ähm ja immer mehr Möglichkeiten haben, diese Gesellschaft zu bestimmen,
und die diese Möglichkeiten der Einflussnahme,
nicht noch nicht einmal bösartig selber ausnutzen, sondern eigentlich etwas Schlimmeres machen, nämlich die Mais bieten an Dritte zu verkaufen. Ja, was was eigentlich noch viel krasser ist, ja? Und,
Das ist, denke ich, der Hauptgrund, warum man einen solchen Dienst lieber nicht nutzen möchte. Hm und das ist der Hauptgrund, warum man sich vielleicht sagt, ach weißt du was?
Ich möchte gerne diesen Dienst ähm Messenger ist ja relativ simples,
Produkt, ja, du schreibst eine Nachricht in Ägypten-Server und der leitet die an den anderen weiter, ne. Dann gibt's noch eine Verschlüsselung dazu. Das kannst du mit ein paar paar Leuten bauen. Ich glaube, WhatsApp hatte beim zum Zeitpunkt des Kaufs irgendwie sechzig Mitarbeiter, ne
und wurde für neunzehn Milliarden US-Dollar verkauft. Also hier ging's nicht.
Ich glaube es waren sogar noch weniger, glaube ich, sogar.
Sogar noch weniger.
Und zwar auch keine Pearlscripte.
Ja, es war eher lang, aber äh.
Genau, es war Erlangen, äh Erlangen auf den Servern und äh Krude, Kruder, äh Krüppel-Code auf den auf den Geräten. Also
das war nicht die Kohle wert, ja? Das war nicht die, das waren nicht die neunzehn Milliarden, die die Facebooker ausgegeben hat, sondern die Nutzerinnen waren das,
und das Beibehalten der Marktmacht, ja? Und deswegen denke ich, sollte man diese Gelegenheit nutzen.
Und die Welle reiten und eben beispielsweise zu Threema oder Signal wechseln, Threema wird von ich glaube kostet inzwischen, ich hab.
Mich haben die nie großartig nach Geld gefragt, aber inzwischen muss man, glaube ich, pro Jahr vier Euro zahlen oder sowas, weiß ich noch nicht mal,
auf jeden Fall jetzt irgendwie gerade auch ihren Code und hatten so eine Aktion, dass man zum halben Preis da mit rein kam. Also da denke ich, ne, wenn das Unternehmen als Geschäftsmodell hat, einen sicheren Messenger anzubieten, dann kann man denen auch gerne Geld geben,
signal wird von einer Non-Profit-Stiftung betrieben.
Und wenn man sich dann mal anschaut, wie also ne, für wenige Millionen, ist es möglich, so einen Service zu betreiben.
Ähm das ist doch vielleicht einfach das viel angenehmere Modell zu wissen, diejenigen, die hier,
diesen Messenger anbieten, die haben einfach nur ein einziges Ziel und Geschäftsmodell, nämlich mir diesen Messenger anzubieten,
und das finde ich äh unterstützenswert und deswegen rate ich gerne dazu, äh zu Signal, zu wechseln und äh zu Threema zu wechseln und gerade denke ich, der Wechsel zu Signal ist äh,
enorm äh einfach
und enorm simpel, insbesondere für für WhatsApp-Nutzer. Und ich denke, da kann man sich an dem etwas aufgewärmt äh aufgeräumteren UI durchaus erfreuen. Ähm
Kernunterschied zwischen WhatsApp und äh zwischen Signal und Threema.
Bleibt. Signal ist noch immer an die Telefonnummer gebunden. Das heißt, wenn ihr mit jemandem über Signal kommunizieren möchtet, müsst ihr der Person.
Eben auch eure Telefonnummer geben, was potenziell,
einige Leute nicht möchten. Bei Threema gibt es eine andere ID als die Telefonnummer, nämlich einfach so einen kryptischen Code. Das ist im Prinzip der Fingerprint eures Kryptokies oder daraus abgeleitet. Und,
hat den Vorteil, ja, dass man jetzt beispielsweise vollständig anonym einen Threemer-Account äh betreiben kann.
Das sind also zwei die die zwei primären Unterschiede. Zweitens hat Signal das von mir sehr geschätzte Feature der verschwindenden Nachrichten, dass man also sagen kann alles was in diesem Chat steht wird nach fünf Sekunden bis was weiß ich Monate
gelöscht einfach, um da so ein bisschen Datensparsamkeit äh walten zu lassen. Das hat natürlich auch äh durchaus Vorteile. Also beide,
denke ich, äh kann man, weil sie Open Source sind und weil sie von lauteren Personen betrieben werden, die keine.
Gegenüber haben. Mit gutem Gewissen nutzen und ähm es muss halt einfach einmal dieser Netzwerkeffekt erreicht sein, damit
Damit die etabliert sind, weil der die meisten Leute sagen, sie sind bei WhatsApp, weil ihre Freunde da sind. Na dann zieht doch mal mit euren Freunden nach Signal um und jeder nimmt drei Freunde mit, dann ist das Problem auch geklärt oder Threema oder oder.
Ja, wenn's immer nur Freunde werden, ne. Oft sind es natürlich eher so Klassenverbunde.
Ja, aber keine Ahnung. Ich alle sagen, alle erzählen mir von den Eltern äh Gruppen auf WhatsApp, ne. Und ich höre von niemandem, dass das irgendwie eine besonders angenehme Erfahrung wäre. Muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen.
Davon hat ja überhaupt keiner gesprochen.
Aber du willst halt an bestimmten Kanälen dann einfach teilnehmen, weil du sozusagen gar keine Option hast, ne? Weil entweder bist du komplett raus, ja?
Na ja, das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass diese Lösung.
Sehr viel besser werden und da auch einfach technologisch mithalten können. Grundsätzlich ist das natürlich auch für die Zukunft interessantes Modell, dass man eben solche,
solche unabhängigen Gruppen, äh auch vielleicht öffentlich finanziert,
ja? Und um einfach sicherzustellen, dass äh auf der Basis auch relevante Internetstandards sich entwickeln können, weil man muss ja auch sagen, diese Messenger sind,
am Ende auch ein ähm ja Zeuge des Versagens eigentlich der.
Entwicklung offener Standards. Die Chatsysteme, die vorher da waren, die lange propagiert wurden und die quasi empfohlen wurden, so auf, nur weil's frei ist, nur weil's offen ist, konnten dann einfach Feature mäßig überhaupt nicht mithalten,
gehört so ein bisschen zu den Projekten, die da eben so eine Anti-These äh aufgezogen haben.
Genau, es ist also der, es gab einmal natürlich die Debatte zwischen dezentrale und zentrale Systeme, ja, aber es gibt da noch eben eine zweite und das ist das, was hier Signal und Threema, denke ich, besonders hingekriegt haben. Die haben zwar gesagt, ja, zentralisiertes System,
aber eben ähm.
Und haben die Vorteile maximal in zwei Cut äh beim, ich glaube beim sechsunddreißig C drei einen sehr schönen Vortrag drüber gehalten. Ähm über eben dezentral und zentrales System kann man unterschiedliche Auffassungen zu haben, ja?
Ist aber hier gerade nicht nicht unbedingt äh der Debattengegenstand. Entscheidend finde ich erstmal überhaupt zu sagen so,
Das System wird betrieben mit der Absicht, dieses System zu betreiben und nicht mit der Absicht irgendwelche äh sonstigen Daten zu sammeln. Und dieser Wechsel auf so einen anderen Messenger, wenn man jetzt diese ganze Datenschutzsache, wo sich immer zu,
Insbesondere besonders ich werde nicht müde, das zu betonen. Ähm das muss man als ein kollektives Problem sehen und nicht als ein individuelles.
Und wenn man das als ein kollektives Problem sieht, ne, dann ist das eigentlich das am einfachsten zu lösende. Andere kollektive Probleme, die wir haben, betreffen Klimawandel. Ähm,
äh die Massentierhaltung
Ähm was weiß ich, Autofahrten und Individualverkehr, das sind mal richtig nennenswerte fette ähm kollektive Probleme, ja? Und da musst du musst du, was weiß ich, Jahrzehnte dran arbeiten. Und wenn dein kollektives Problem ist
äh für eine Basalfunktion, die irgendwie jeder ähm.
Die die jedes Team von drei Personen an einem Wochenende im Prinzip bauen kann in der Programmiersprache ihrer Wahl.
Wenn wenn das um diese Dienstleistung geht und alles was du machen musst, um dieses kollektive Problem wegzunehmen, ist die eine App löschen und eine andere installieren, dann denke ich, ist das das
kleinste kollektive Problem, was wir lösen können. Ja, also jedes andere kollektive Problem ist sehr viel schwieriger zu lösen. Na ja, also,
WhatsApp Signal macht das, Hauptsache Signal, Hauptsache kein WhatsApp.
Ich wollte nochmal ganz kurz noch was zur Corona-Warn-App sagen, weil jetzt natürlich, also es ist, du kannst dir ja also,
Wenn du diese Borispalmen und wie sie alle heißen, was die für.
Was die reden und was die anrichten, das ist ja wirklich eine einzige Katastrophe, wurde ich hier durch einen Tweet drauf aufmerksam von ähm,
der Account heißt FDP-Spendenkonto-Account finde ich zeigte er hat irgendwie seiner Mutter.
Seine Mutter aufgeklärt über die Funktionalität der Corona-Warnapp und dann hat die Mutter diese äh Corona-Warn-App installiert und dann hat sie äh,
von was weiß ich, Onkel Günther, den Zeitungsartikel äh in äh auf Heise DE geschickt bekommen, wo steht,
Friedrich Merz möchte die Nutzer der Corona-Warn-App orten und dann hat Mutti die Corona App gelöscht.
Ja? Genau das, was äh was klar war, was passieren würde, ja? Und da.
Da redet dieser Typ einfach nur vor sich hin, finde ich ja sowieso faszinierend, was der so vor sich hinredet. Boris Palmer ebenfalls äußerst faszinierend
Ähm der steckt hier mit diesem äh Niederrümelin unter einer Decke und die machen sich keine Gedanken darüber, was sie anrichten. Ähm ich wie gesagt, ich wurde da auch nochmal in so einer Presseanfrage zu äh befragt.
Und hab dann mal erklärt ne was das das eben wie viele die App nutzen, der wichtigste Erfolgsfaktor für so 'ne App ist und wenn da irgendwie Palmer und März Raubbau daran betreiben, dann wird wird die App nur noch schlechter und ich denke das Entscheidende, was ich da gesagt habe, ist,
mit mehr Datenschutz oder weniger Datenschutz wird die App genau so gut funktionieren wie vorher, aber keinesfalls besser, weil,
wenn die Nutzungszahlen sinken, das ist der wichtigste Faktor, den diese App hat,
und danke Friedrich Merz, der jetzt schon die Leute äh warnt, äh dass sie sich möglichst diese App deinstallieren sollen, ist wirklich ähm.
Äh wirklich bedauerlich, was was da passiert und äh ja, man kann nur hoffen, dass dieser Sprüche Klopper ähm irgendwie wieder in seine Sprücherklopperloch verschwindet,
Gute Nachricht oder ich weiß nicht, ist das eine gute Nachricht, Tim? Zwanzig Jahre Wikipedia, gute Nachricht, schlechte Nachricht, gute Nachricht.
Ich finde das eine eine gute Nachricht. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was daran eine schlechte Nachricht sein sollte. Ich meine, es ist wirklich eins der wenigen ähm ja, es ist.
Würde ich sogar fast sagen, vielleicht überhaupt das erfolgreichste,
sehr freien Internetlandschaft. Also da würde mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt nix einfallen, was auch nur ansatzweise in dieser Region mitspielt.
Wahnsinnsding.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch an die Community. Vielen Dank an die Autorinnen und Autorin und Moderatorinnen, die dieses Projekt seit zwanzig Jahren da pflegen. Das ist eine eine geglückte Revolution des Wissens
ja, die ähm eigentlich Maßstäbe für viele setzt. Und das ist.
Und,
Ja und fleischgewordenes Science-Fiction. Also das ging echt schnell. So, ich meine, ein paar Anhalte durch die Galaxis haben wir in den achtziger Jahren war das ja sozusagen noch so so eine so eine fabulierte Zukunft.
Ja, das kleine Lexikon, was jeder dabei hat und wo alle irgendwie was reinschreiben,
und dann kam's halt einfach, zack, bumm und ist dann schnell gewachsen und schnell gereift und es gibt sicherlich eine ganze Latte von äh Dingen, wo man jetzt anfangen könnte, ja, aber Wikipedia und hier und da ein Problem und so weiter, ja,
klar. Natürlich, aber auf der anderen Seite ähm was Wikipedia ermöglicht hat.
Lässt sich äh nicht in hundert Seiten aufschreiben. Das ist einfach äh so ein NABler auf auf so vielen Andi. Es gibt, glaube ich, keine Webseite, die ich häufiger aufrufe, jeden Tag.
Keine.
Er ist wirklich ein also ein ganz großartige äh Revolution, die da stattgefunden. Ich hätte nur zu jetzt zum zwanzigjährigen eine Bitte an Wikipedia. Ähm könnte bitte jemand in meinem Wikipedia eintragen, dass Netzaktivist streichen.
Ah!
Ey, das ist so eine Katastrophe und da könnte auch mal ein neues Bild hin. Ich ich stelle gerne eins bereit, ja. Aber es ist.
Du kannst es doch selber machen, Linus.
Ey, an so vielen Stellen kommst du, ähm nee, ich kann bei Wikipedia nichts ändern. Kann ich nicht.
Weil äh weil Tor und VPNs dort gesperrt sind und deswegen kann ich Wikipedia nicht effitieren.
Und das ist so
Aber äh also es wäre sehr schön, wenn dieses Netzaktivist da wegkäme. Ich finde das total unschön, diese ich fühle mich nicht als Netzaktivist, ich bin keiner und ich möchte auch keiner sein.
Ich finde das so blöd, weil alle schreiben das ab, ja? Also es ist wirklich so, ja hallo Herr Neumann, wir haben da mal hier unsere Moderator würde sie folgendermaßen vorstellen, Linus Neumann ist Hacker, Netzaktivist und einer
des Chaos Computerclubs der Diplompsychologe lebt
und arbeitet in Berlin als Berater für IT-Sicherheit. Wo ich dann immer so denke so, Leute, das ist schön, was ihr euch da zusammen recherchiert habt, ne, also,
peinlich. Äh peinlich. Also das wäre schön, ähm bin gerne bereit, da.
Ich habe da äh ich hätte also wenn's wenn du so anfängst so, ich meine nicht so, dass ich das Problem nicht auch hätte. Ich meine das.
Also ich sag's jetzt hier, äh ich bin kein Netzaktivist und damit habt ihr eine Quelle, damit ihr das da raus löschen könnt.
Kein Eventmanager.
So, danke. Und äh ja dieses dieses Bild, ja, keine Ahnung, es ist
Ne, alles super. Ich finde, ich finde Wikipedia wirklich cool, aber das, das ärgert mich und das ist nicht ein Fehler von Wikipedia, sondern das ist ein Fehler von diesen Leuten, die das irgendwie abschreiben. Ähm,
sich nicht die Mühe geben da.
Ja, ich meine, bei mir steht auch irgendwas drin, dass ich mal eine Mailing-Liste begründet habe als als ob das äh ja.
Ich habe mal die McHackers Mailing-Liste gestartet. Ich meine, das ist einfach,
eine fucking Mailing, das wo Leute, die irgendwie Max benutzen, irgendwie äh quatschen und die läuft glücklicherweise auch heute noch und ist auch immer noch friedlich. Aber das ist einfach keine Information für eine Wikipedia-Seite so, ja.
Froh, dass das nicht oben steht, sonst würdest du die ganze Zeit so vorgestellt werden.
Da oben steht, dass ich ein deutsch-britischer Event-Manager bin.
Dicker, also ich bitte dich, also erstmal ist gut, meinetwegen, ja, mag ja sein, dass ich äh wie beides bin, aber Eventmanager, nur weil ich mal irgendwie Camp und Kongress ein bisschen was gemacht habe, wirklich, also,
Na ja, egal. Aber immer entstehen ein paar äh stehen auch ein paar richtige Sachen drin. So ist es nicht und gar nicht so viel falsch. Im Moment steht drin, dass ich auch mal äh Programmierer des Monats ähm,
geworden bin.
Woah wo?
Input vierundsechzig.
Ach so, ich dachte, bei Beate Uhse, da hast du ja auch mal gearbeitet.
Nee, da da hätte ich sie den Titel sicherlich auch verdient gehabt, aber ich habe das äh seinerzeit neunzehnhundertfünfundachtzig bin ich Programmierer des äh Monats geworden im Heise Verlag. So viel möchte ich.
Oh! Okay, nee, das ist äh.
Input vierundsechzig, das war das äh das erste äh Magazin, was auf das Kette ausgeliefert wurde, das im Prinzip der Vorläufer des äh weltweit Web.
Okay, das ist ein Titel. Das ist ein Titel.
Titel war auch ein gutes Programm, muss ich mal dazu sagen. Also es war wirklich gut. Für damalige.
Der gehört dahin.
Ja seitdem ging's ja ein bisschen bergab mit meiner Programmier äh Karriere, aber damals war ich noch fit.
Na ja, wenn du einmal am Zenit warst, dann kannst dich auch zurücklehnen.
Ja, da ruhe ich mich bis heute äh noch äh drauf aus. Wie lange ist das jetzt her? Oh Gott, das ist ja oh Gott! Das will ich überhaupt nicht drüber nachdenken, wie lange das her ist. Sind das fünfunddreißig Jahre? Gott, meine Herren.
Tja.
Dann äh kommen wir noch zu einer äh ganz kurzen Meldung hier äh zum Ende. Ich habe einen Anschlusstermin und werde langsam nervös. Ähm.
Einem Regensburger äh Straffall.
Hat ein Gericht. Ähm das ist jetzt schon eine etwas ältere Meldung aus Mitte Dezember, die wir aber nicht behandelt haben. Und zwar äh wurde hier, wurden hier die Aufzeichnungen,
Alexa,
von einem Gericht angefordert, ausgewertet und als Beitrag genutzt, den Mann des äh Totschlags seiner Ehefrau.
Oder seiner Ex-Freundin ähm überführt zu haben.
Ähm das heißt, das Gericht hat diese Sprachaufnahmen, die durch den äh durch diesen Sprachassistenten in der Cloud angefertigt werden, als äh.
Beweismittel zugelassen und angefordert gemäß Paragraph einhundertzehn der Strafprozessordnung in diesen einhundert A bis Z sind diese ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen Wohnraumüberwachung und sowas alles geregelt.
Und äh ja, haben tatsächlich äh ist natürlich relativ kompliziert, wo steht der Server und so weiter und Amazon hat dann diese Daten äh freiwillig übermittelt
und äh an die Staatsanwaltschaft und das Gericht hat die zugelassen und damit ähm.
Ist jetzt quasi auch in Deutschland äh der Fall geschaffen, dass eben der Zugriff auf solche ähm.
Hope, Smart Home Geräte äh offenbar unter Paragraph einhundert STPO,
zugelassen wird. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob da nochmal irgendwie gegen vorgegangen wird oder so, es war natürlich auch irgendwie zu erwarten, dass das passieren würde.
Und nun ja, ähm.
Es ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder ein konkreter Fall, ne. Ich meine, da hat ein Mann eine Frau getötet, so da will man natürlich auch, dass der ähm einer Strafe zugeführt wird, gleichzeitig ähm ist das natürlich.
Der Teufel an die Wand malen, aber es ist eben regelmäßig so, dass solche Eingriffe bei den schweren Verbrechen beginnen und dann zu der Alltags,
Kriminalität durchträufeln, also als beispielsweise als Person, die sich auf den Handel mit äh seltenen äh Substanzen,
spezialisiert hat, würde ich jetzt mal zusehen, dass ich so ein Ding nicht in der Hütte stehen hätte, ne. Aber äh.
Als Entwicklung sollte man das äh hier erwähnt haben.
Damit sind wir, glaube ich, so am am Ende. Wir werden, wir haben hier so zwei Themen, die wahrscheinlich erwartet werden von uns so ein bisschen außen vor gelassen, wo wir hoffen,
uns eventuell mit äh Spezialen äh in nächster Zeit denen äh zu widmen. Insofern hoffen wir, ihr bleibt uns gewogen.
Und ähm wir freuen uns auch tatsächlich über äh Feedback, also das Feedback in zu die Kommentare.
Sind, ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, in letzter Zeit hat das zugenommen an Kommentaren mit ja irgendwie Ergänzungen und Richtigstellungen, die mir,
ich auch nicht so auf dem Schirm hatte. Sei das jetzt hier zum Thema Singapur, den hatten wir ja gerade mit aufgenommen. Außerdem hatten wir auch einen Kommentar, der sehr sich ausführlicher mit diesem ganzen Universum, um,
die Intercept und so auseinandergesetzt hat, also quasi.
Also es war ein relativ langer Kommentar, der sich damit auseinandersetzt, so wie was sind jetzt eigentlich die Unterschiede zwischen Julian Assange und AdWord Snowden und das sind äh sehr ähm,
Ergänzungen. Nicht alle nehmen wir dann in die Sendung auf, weil es vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen äh aus.
Sich ein bisschen sehr weit entwickelt von unseren Kernthemen weg oder so dass wir das jetzt nicht unbedingt als Feedback zur Sendung mit aufnehmen aber wir haben da in letzter Zeit,
irgendwie ganz gefühlt eine Zunahme an echt wertstiftenden Kommentaren, also schaut da gerne mal rein,
und äh lasst gerne euer äh Feedback da, das äh freut mich immer sehr. Das wollte ich noch mal so sagen.
Das hast du gut gesagt. Ja.
Gut gesagt, ne? Und weißt du was Tim? Ich habe vergessen dem Geroll zu danken.
Deswegen danke ich nochmal dem Gerold. Wirklich sorry, das äh ist irgendwie.
Es ist jetzt sozusagen der letzte.
Dein Name ist äh irgendwie nicht auf der Liste gewesen. Und damit bist du jetzt vielleicht bist du der Letzte, dem äh zwanzig zwanzig noch gedankt wurde. Vielen Dank Gerold.
Dann haben wir's. Das war's. Die Politik dreihundertsechsundsiebzig ist in the Can. Ja und dann entlassen wir euch erstmal und wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder.
Ihr seid entlassen und das Schöne ist, uns dreht zu schnell keiner die Server ab, weil wir selber hosten.
Wir sind ja so klug. Na ja. Tschüss.
Ciao ciao.